it oh man we got it we got a lag here
yeah jesse smolette is guilty
guilty on five of six counts and i'm
really confused as to how they didn't
find him guilty on the sixth count but
uh they didn't either way i guess each
charge carries a maximum penalty of
three years in prison which will never
happen i mean come on they're to be like
jesse smilet you owe the court 50
and that's gonna be the end of it no
probably not i think he might get a
heavy finding probation but we'll see we
got a lot to break down we've got uh um
we've got some some great tweets to
bring up from the president and the vice
president about how they were supporting
this man how many were so we'll get into
all that stuff with justice millet he's
saying he will be filing an appeal which
is the most insane thing i've ever heard
considering how stupid his defense was
and we all expected this to happen and
then it did
we also got a bunch of other crazy news
the prime minister of finland went out
clubbing wasn't answering her phone
we've got this one uh is this one blew
my mind joe biden the administration is
effectively telling ukraine to surrender
their eastern front to russian-backed
separatists to just give them autonomy
in the region to some degree and this is
biden basically saying putin you've won
we're giving you we're waving that we've
waived the sanctions on the gas pipeline
we don't got anything else here and this
one's a little tough because in my
opinion we i agree with tucker when he
said why do we care about ukraine's
border he's right so if this avoids war
why should i care about ukraine and if
joe biden doesn't
but my concern is like with afghanistan
he's blundering our foreign policy worse
than it should be i mean getting out of
afghanistan was the right thing to do
but not the way he did it so we're going
to get into all that and joining us
today is jan ikelek of the epoch times
you want to introduce yourself well
really great to be on the show here um
yeah i'm a senior editor with epoch
times i i host american thought leaders
on epoch tv on our streaming platform
and on ntd now on cable 23 million cable
households that's pretty awesome i'm
kind of shocked to be on there a bit
um no and we we we've been bringing on
some pretty pretty interesting people
especially lately a lot of people that
are you know basically talking honestly
about the scientists that are talking
honestly about the realities of
coronavirus and the policies and
everything else
cool man well glad to have you we got
luke here as well
the best political shirt
i don't think you need a translation i
think it's pretty clear what he wants to
get across right
now i can translate this i can translate
this he said i need to make money
buy my t-shirts please
tell us
hippies
i wanted to confirm that it is both
epoch times and and epoch times
depending on if you're uh american
english british english you know you say
epoch because so they don't mix it up
and think it's epic epic that's right
it's epoch so i'm kind of of the school
i'm trying to bring in everyone over to
epoch epoch epoch right because you can
it's phonetic you can hear it
yeah well i'm ian crossland happy to be
here ian crossland.net what up i'm also
here getting my language lesson in
polish tonight we only need jackpot here
to complete the trifecta of polish dude
so that would be fun maybe next time he
doesn't speak polish though he doesn't
no he speaks mandarin no but he speaks
mandarin it's pretty impressive actually
yeah
all right tim yeah before we get started
we got an awesome sponsor we have
biotrust's keto elevate c8 mct oil
powder that is a mouthful but this is
effectively like a powdered fat
supplement so if you're doing keto you
mix it into your coffee and your
smoothies into your food or drinks
whatever and it's actually pretty good i
like mixing in my coffee because it's it
makes it like it's like creamy right so
um if you go to eat right and
feelwell.com you will get 51 percent off
of your mct oil part that's medium chain
triglycerides and let me just say
something my friends if you go back a
few months go back maybe five months on
this show and you'll notice that i was
looking much more plump that's true over
the past few months i've actually uh
started i've tried to eat right i've
been eating a lot better i've been doing
keto actually and it's not very strict
but i've basically cut out 99 of all the
carbs that i eat which means i still eat
you know a little bit and i've been
adding stuff like biotrusts keto elevate
powder to my coffee in the morning so
i'm just basically having coffee and fat
and i'm feeling better than i've ever
felt that's just me personally i don't
want to give you advice but if you are
looking for something like this again go
to eatrightandfeelwell.com and biotrust
says you get a 60-day money-back
guarantee
keto elevate provides your body only c8
the most ketogenic mct that means it
will provide support for high energy
levels healthy appetite management
mental clarity and focus athletic
performance they say keto elevate uh you
get free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor to date they
to date
biotrust has provided over five million
meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you get free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order i gotta say i
feel fantastic i felt better than i felt
in a really really long time and uh you
if you want to you know feel good too
you can go to eatrightandfeelwell.com
special thanks to biotrust for
sponsoring the show don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member look at this
we got a big old breaking story on the
front page just found guilty written by
tim poole
with uh there should be an extra
additional byline credit for chris carr
who's our executive editor who really
filled it out i just got it started but
when you are a member you're helping
support our team of journalists so we
can break the news we can report on a
variety of issues not all of it is it
we're trying to avoid playing the stupid
rage bait and i'll tell you guys
something i'll be the first to admit it
we had an article up about this shopping
karen who accused the black man of
stealing her cell phone we had a couple
comments saying like what is this you
know race bait rage bait garbage and
i saw it and i talked to the team and i
was like hey guys i think this is a
little low brow we should be sticking to
good journalism so we decided to take it
down full disclosure that is an
editorial note we are telling you right
on the show we strive to be the best of
the best because we are beholden just to
you guys as members we're not trying to
chase clicks we're just trying to make
sure when you're a member you get access
to good well-researched and fact-checked
information but you're also going to get
members only segments from the tim cast
irl podcast we will have that up for you
around 11 p.m tonight so again that's
timcast.com
some people have been asking about how
to become a member and they've been
accidentally joining the youtube
membership but it as it is at
timcast.com that's where to go don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share this show with all
your friends let's get into the big
breaking news my friends ladies and
gentlemen from timcast.com jesse
smallett found guilty on first five
counts of felony disorderly conduct not
guilty on count six
former empire actor has been found
guilty
deliberations lasted just over nine
hours with the jury delivering the
verdict thursday evening around 6 15 p.m
some was acquitted on count six of
felony disorderly conduct which refers
to the defendant reporting to detective
robert graves on february 14 2019 about
two weeks after the incident that he'd
been the victim of an aggravated robbery
all other charges were related to the
events that took place on january 29
2019 as it stands judge james lynn will
have the discretion in imposing a
concurrent or consecutive sentence for
smilet on each count at a later date a
disorderly conduct charge for false
crime report is a class iv felony which
means it is punishable by up to three
years in prison and a twenty-five
thousand dollar fine somali took the
stand and testified before the jury that
he never lied to the police and denied
orchestrating the attack on himself
however it goes a little bit beyond just
that um according to one report we
covered the other day the prosecutor in
the closing arguments accused smilet of
perjury
many different news outlets and
columnists said
sure does look like smollett just
perjured himself so he may try to get
out of this one somehow he's going to
try and appeal but he could get charged
with perjury now now as for a prison
time i don't know what you guys i don't
i don't think it'll happen i think he's
going to get a slap on the wrist they're
going to be like we've got too many
political allies he's super wealthy what
he'll pay a fine and then he's disgraced
is that is that all we're gonna get out
of this or would you cross our fingers
hope he goes to jail
well i mean was anyone concerned that
you know i saw that for example blm came
out with a statement basically saying
you know we we support his position here
which i thought was fascinating because
this is you know i i still remember the
police chief
you know coming out and saying you know
we spent 200 hours
on chase on this wild goose chase this
is this is a you know horrible we can't
we can't do this right this is
you never see police chiefs coming out
and sort of you know basically saying
this this guy's guilty et cetera et
cetera you just you just don't see it it
was so open and shut and how where what
did the prosecution what were they
thinking
putting together this uh particular uh
sorry the defense i mean what was the
defense thinking putting together this
did you did you see their their defense
did you see what they tried to do yeah
like accuse the judge of lunging at you
then demand a mistrial then demand a
mistrial over not being allowed to
cross-examine properly which was bunk
and then nearly crying and running out
of the courtroom with your mother that's
quite literally what the defense one of
the defense lawyers for smolette did
yeah the blm comment is is big that you
mentioned earlier because it was a blm
leader molina uh abdullah who said that
black lives matter stands in solidarity
solidarity with juicy smolette because
we could never believe the police uh now
i i believe also blair white had a very
interesting comment about this she said
poor smoulet i hope he doesn't beat
himself up over this
which i thought was very fitting there's
also a lot of jokes about the the juice
being squeezed but uh you know this
sends a message to a lot of people if
you try to divide this country if you
fake a hate crime there's going to be
some ramifications for it what are those
ramifications is he going to get uh
probation is he going to have to pay a
heavy fine is he going to go to jail uh
well we're only going to see because i
think that's up for the judge to decide
not the prosecutor right yeah it's it's
well i don't know if it's the judge i
believe the judge will will will issue
sentencing it's not gonna be the
prosecutor but um
whether he goes to jail will be
interesting so he's got five felony
counts i believe they're five felony
counts each with three years and the
judge could be like that's 15 years
buddy
i really doubt that but but some people
are saying it might be a year i mean
it's a felony so they might be like look
so typically when you're convicted of a
misdemeanor they have a a jail sentence
not a prison sentence of up to one year
so i don't know how it works outside of
illinois but i can say in illinois my
understanding it's been a long time
since since i was studying this stuff
is that if you
commit a misdemeanor they can at most
put you in jail for 364 days that would
be like cook county jail not a prison
not a state penitentiary but once you
cross that threshold into a year they
move you to one of the like you know
maximum security prisons or state
prisons and that's where things are
really bad
like really bad so
small i think if he's going to go to
jail it's going to be a year isn't it
yeah but it won't be like a maximum
security thing i'm sure right even
though it's technically a felony i don't
know i don't know this is a violent i
mean how would you classify this i mean
it's it's a class four felony so it's
the weakest of felonies right and he
didn't like beat an old lady or anything
like that right but it's not a
white-collar crime it's not like they're
gonna put him in a golf resort well the
the crime to me is you know
the police are needed in chicago you
know the police are needed in this city
you know and then this is like i think
they said 200 hours that were used to
basically
you know
follow a wild goose chase that was not
that that that is a terrible terrible
thing for a city with that level of
crime i would argue that they're doing a
very poor job because of the high level
of crime because how the government uh
has been implementing policy theirs i
mean the district attorney in chicago is
kim fox she went out of her way to make
sure that juicy smallett wasn't facing
any charges at all she was clearly a
huge conflict of interest since she was
friends with him friends with the obamas
friends would have a lot a lot of highly
connected people so i bet on appeal
there's going to be a lot of finagling i
think there's going to be more to this
case that are going to surprise the rest
of america because if you remember this
was a heinous case that motivated the
establishment to scream out and point
out against trump supporters and say
these are really horrible people this is
the example that we need to stand on we
need to make sure that this never
happens again and then poof we all found
out that it was all hoax all made up i
want to pull up we did briefly pull up
the black lives matter state yeah we
have it here from their website december
7th statement regarding the ongoing
trial of jesse smallett
they say
i'm not going to read the whole thing
but in our commitment to abolition we
can never believe police especially the
chicago police department over jesse
smilet a black man who has been
courageously present visible and vocal
in the struggle for black freedom while
policing at large is an irredeemable
institution cpd is notorious for its
long and deep history of corruption
racism and brutality now i'll tell you
i'll tell you here's the here's the
challenge i face but i think the
decision is still simple uh being from
chicago which people like to point out
in the chat i say a lot but i don't
really think i said that often but i'm
from there and i've dealt with bad cops
i've had cops screw with me and as much
as i have issues with like the black
site they were operating that's where
they were secretly taking people and
detaining them they've done to activists
i have seen there there was one viral
moment in chicago where a meter maid
gave a cop a ticket so he like grabbed
her by the neck and slammed her and
lifted up against the wall there was
another video where a bunch of off-duty
cops beat the crap out of a bartender so
i've seen the bad cops chicago and with
all that i've experienced when i saw
this story i said the cops are telling
the truth right like jesse smallett's
story is so stupid and dangerous it's
really dangerous
it was it was a smear against half the
country and the president and it rallied
a bunch of people into believing this
crackpot bs about trump that bothers me
if we're gonna have a conversation about
what's true we need to sit down i've sat
down at many hit many dinner tables with
trump supporters and we've had great
conversations on racism in this country
and you'd be surprised how many of them
were like yeah i understand that but
these people want to tell you i mean
actually maybe none of us here would be
surprised back oh yeah we get it but
these people want you to believe they're
all demon white supremacists evil maga
country lurking around
black lives matter this statement is so
insane come on
like
i'm surprised they were willing to do
something so dumb and that is with
respect to understanding the problems in
the chicago police department
i don't know how you can possibly say
something like you can never believe a
given set of people and expect people to
take you seriously that's clearly so
purely ideologically motivated why would
anyone take anything you have to say
with any degree of seriousness yes just
broad brushing an entire group it was
same with believe all women i thought
that's so ridiculous because some women
lie and when they do you don't want to
believe them and sometimes you do want
to believe the police because they tell
you the truth so all this hyperbole and
extremity is like
devastating i'll i'll say this like you
know i i mentioned this
half jokingly i'm like what if it turns
out you know uh smut's telling the truth
well now he's been convicted by a jury
of his peers so he's guilty he did it
right um well you know we'll see what
happens with appeal perhaps people can
be evicted but i just i think his story
outright was just the stupidest thing
anyone had ever heard laughably bad but
maybe you know during the trial i'm like
maybe there's a chance that the oh
sunday brothers actually are
sophisticated criminals who set him all
up that's why i kept saying innocent
until proven guilty and though i think
we we
reasonably believe he's guilty and
secret homophobes and white supremacists
at the same time so yeah skin and pale
skin and pale skin
yeah light skin but but again we also
have to remember charges were initially
dropped against smoulay on march 8th
there was a grand jury indictment
charges were dropped two weeks later and
then there was an outrage because of
that and that's when the chicago police
chief decided to make statements against
this and that's why they called it a
quote whitewash of justice in particular
were interesting words chosen there for
this particular incident but kim fox
this whole time was saying that the
charges were excessive she of course is
heavily connected she did recuse herself
from originally charging uh juice moulet
so obviously on the appeal i would look
out for more finagling
more political intervention during this
case because this was political from the
very beginning we saw kamala harris get
involved in this we saw joe biden get
involved in this and they were using
this for their own political power
yep this is a long trend there's a
there's there's a book about hate crime
hoaxes there's a website tracking hate
hate crime hoaxes and jesse smellet was
just capitalizing off of what we had
already seen mega dangerous like it it
it was it is stupid what he did but it's
so dangerous not only did he waste cops
time like you were saying earlier 100
hours of 100 200 either that's 200 man
hours or 200 hours of like patrol groups
of cops going out i don't know 200 man
hours let's say that's at 40 bucks an
hour you know what is that 80 thousand
dollars 40 bucks 20 bucks an hour
somewhere 50 to 80 000 that's wasted
just an hourly wages is wasted so he
should pay all that back no there's
something they're swimming for it when
it comes to punishment throwing a guy in
jail for ten years i don't know but
allowing a high profile person to fake a
hate crime is super dangerous we cannot
let people do that in society we do we
do have an update here from the
associated press as well from just a few
minutes before the show started
smollette attorney says ex-empire actor
will appeal the verdict justice matt's
defense attorney said thursday he will
appeal the former empire actor's
conviction for lying to police about the
the being the victim of a racist
anti-gay attack a jury found smollett
guilty this we now know after the vote
was read ooch told reporters simolette
was disappointed and that he was 100
percent innocent he said smollett's team
is confident he's going to be cleared of
all all accusations on all charges at a
certain point i just have to say dude
guy give it up man
apologize
just if he had come out and said look
i was just trying to bring attention to
you know racism and i thought people
weren't listening and it was stupid i'd
have still been like screw this guy you
know what i mean but a lot of people
probably have been like all right all
right he fessed up he admitted it and my
response typically is okay here's what
i'll do
if you come out admit it and apologize i
will give you a second chance you know
why
if you don't their only option is to go
the other direction so if smallett does
something bad and everyone hates him for
it and then he comes out and says yo i
shouldn't have done that it was a huge
mistake i'll say all right bro i'm cool
with it i'm cool with that never do it
again and we're good because i want you
to keep walking towards the light and
away from the darkness
if you if you attack him for and say
screw you i'll never forgive you he'll
be like darkness it is we don't want any
of that if i was working for smoulette
and i was a part of his pr team i would
have been like okay we're bringing the
bloods and the crypts together we're
bringing the trump supporters and blm
together we're going to use this
opportunity to see what we have in
common with each other and we're going
to have a sit down and we're going to
work our differences out and actually
show that we could be civilized humane
throughout all of this and not let
political discourse ruin our humanity
that's what i would have been doing uh
but uh that's that's too that would help
too much people i think here's what
concerns me okay and this is why like i
was actually worried
that it might be you know it might be a
clean innocent verdict right because
the people that are
running black the black lives matter
organization they subscribe to a very
particular kind of ideology i mean john
mcwhorter
in you know he documents this the
columbia professor and woke racism his
new book um that he sees it as a
religion right i agree and the idea is
right that their perspective on innocent
is because of who he is
he's innocent it doesn't actually matter
what he did right and this is this is
this is a really disturbing way to think
about the world right when you when you
when you really think about it right and
then of course other people will be
structurally innocent some people are
structurally some people are
structurally structurally guilty
and
you know you don't this is why like
you're you asked earlier you said hey
but this is this doesn't make any sense
but to people that are real believers
right in the uh the elect as john
mcwhorter calls them they actually they
think it works that way kind of makes me
think about christianity and how like if
you accept christ into your heart you go
to heaven and if you don't you go to
hell i always never got that it's like
so it doesn't either i i just like i'm
in the club or i'm not in the club it
doesn't matter what i do that doesn't
make any sense to me so it sounds like
black lives matter's adopted that
mentality well there's no forgiveness in
their cult as you brought up very
eloquently when you are wrong where you
when you are the person that's deemed
someone is evil someone who is
institutionally hurting people there's
no coming back from it even if you
apologize you even get attacked by them
even more and this is
apologies are in a mission of guilt so
this is the problem i don't know if
everybody agrees with me unforgiveness
but i think you have to have that
forgiveness it has to there has to be
the capability for someone to come back
to the light
they don't and that means we on the side
of forgiveness and understanding and
logic and reason are the huge's
advantage there and there's pros and
cons i suppose but they're willing to
burn it all down
let me let me pull up these tweets we
have from uh uh defiant ls oh yes we
have joe biden
on one on january 29th 2019 at 8 31 pm i
mean this is basically like the day the
news came out that he did this
joe biden without looking into anything
says what happened today to jesse
smallett must never be tolerated in this
country we must stand up and demand that
we no longer give this hate safe harbor
that homophobia and racism have no place
on our streets and or in our hearts we
are with you jesse and then they attach
this one new york post just to smallet
guilty of staging race-baiting hate
attack to boost career then we get
kamala harris she said jesse smolette is
one of the kindest most gentle human
beings i know i'm praying for his quick
recovery this was an attempted modern
day lynching no one should have to fear
for their life because of their
sexuality or color of their skin we must
confront this hate and then josh kaplan
jury finds actress guilty on five counts
yeah yeah we get it so i'll say this
i would be willing to forgive some
people but probably not jesus millet why
because he is a notorious cult leader
among this this non-theistic religion
that's probably not even fair to say
it's a cult i would not be forgiving
kamala harris or joe biden because at a
certain point it's like look
if you do something bad
and then you get caught and you fess up
and say i shouldn't have done that it
was wrong of me but i thought it was a
path to to wealth and fame and and you
know now that i got caught and it's
threatening to me i'm like i'm gonna try
and stay away from that stuff i'll be
like hey look at that that's honesty
right yeah kamala harris man how often
does she lie how about when kamala
harris tried keeping people in prison
denying them parole so she can use them
as slave labor to fight wildfires
there's not a person i'm gonna forgive
because these people are evil joe biden
too her staff is also resigning in
record numbers saying that she's
scalding them to the level where it's
bringing on ptsd for many people within
her office people are just scared of her
uh and there was this one tweet from
this one poor worker inside of the white
house saying hey for the record i work
for kamala and and everything's great
and it looked almost like the exact
version of that cartoon with fire all
over him saying everything is fine it
was absolutely incredible uh but but you
know these are the people that we're
dealing with people who are hard-headed
people who believe in themselves people
who no matter what will do anything for
power and that's exactly the game that
they're in let's be fair too are the
people who are quitting kamala harris's
uh you know administration already would
call it because she's mean are they
millennials
um
i'm not sure they have to see exactly
the four staff members that left because
there's other complaints from inside so
it has to be a broad range it can't just
be young millennials um i i think that
would be an important factor here
because i'm wondering how much of this
is the coddling of the the american mind
yes you know you've got these young
people who are like come on it came in
and she was upset that i accidentally
put the wrong cream in her coffee and
kamala's like oh hey i asked for a two
cream could you get it fixed for me and
she went
and like just freaked out and i you
think i'm exaggerating too but these
people claim microaggressions are
violence and stuff like that so for all
we know kamala is doing something like
excuse me i told you to bring the packet
upstairs could you please get it done
and they freak out they're like i can't
work here
so based on the fact that she literally
kept people in prison for longer so they
could fight fires when she knew they
were innocent exactly well not not not
mixing two stories there just i'll make
sure we're very careful okay yeah there
were people who were who were about to
be released on parole and her office
argued they should stay so they could be
used as slave labor there was another
individual she knew was innocent and
they tried withholding the evidence to
stop them from getting released i
believe i could be wrong about that last
one there's another fox news story that
says kamala harris staffers leaving
white house in part because they fear
being labeled harris person report
this is a car yeah so that's uh
other articles out there but the the
ones that i saw was
scaring people scolding them destroying
their souls uh which would make sense
from a state prosecutor that has been
absolutely ruthless throughout her
entire career and literally knowingly uh
put innocent people behind uh bars so i
think there's that you know there's
still an opportunity you know you uh tim
you talk about you know this opportunity
for redemption forgiveness this is an
incredibly important feature and you're
very right to say by the way that this
is absent in the
in the you know woke ideology awoke
religion but um you know perhaps they
both both the president and the vice
president can you know seeing this very
guilty verdict and say hey look we were
wrong they're not going to do that
though i mean come on
it's the weird it's the weirdest thing
that um it's not the weirdest thing it's
just it's frustrating that something can
happen with someone on the right and the
people on the right will throw them out
the window in two seconds you know um
like like if you look at what happened
with um the george floyd incident
every single person in the country
immediately jumps on board admittedly so
did i i was like that was wrong we
watched it happen it didn't look good
and then later we start getting more and
more details and we're like okay so it
was kind of a bad situation but it
wasn't as cut and dry as we as we
initially thought
the left doesn't do that i mean we had
that poll yesterday from axios that
young democrats are substantially more
intolerant than young republicans
so this is this is a recurring trend
that is setting
freedom-loving individuals at a
disadvantage we're willing to forgive
we're willing to be tolerant
but the establishment liberal types
democrat types they're not
justice mullet comes out they jump up
and they scream all to high heavens and
demand and what do conservatives do
well not all of them but enough of them
will be like we should recognize this
was bad we'll see how it plays out
how how do we function if they're
willing to lie cheat and steal and then
and then i'll throw it to waukesha
when when a car an suv commits this
atrocity crazy because it gained
sentience yeah and somehow decided to
take these you know it was like
humans
but when we get a man with with black
nationalist sentiment on facebook and
support for black lives matter and he
commits this atrocity
the media drops the story overnight
yeah rest assured if there's a
conservative or right-wing person it
will be non-stop press like we had a guy
go to the ice facility we had a hundred
days of violent riding and firebombing
of a federal building in portland and
the media is like the insurrection was
january 6.
i don't i don't i don't know if it
matters to be completely honest because
i think people see through it i i think
you're right no actually i think that's
exactly that's what i was thinking i
think that's the point i think there's
all these people i mean i keep talking
to people people keep writing we get
tons of mail at epoch times for the show
for the whole for the whole paper and
everything and we have a ton of people
that basically say i feel politically
homeless i've heard mugged by reality
i've heard politically homeless i've
heard you know i don't recognize you
know i i i am a democrat but what what's
happened right like i just i just know i
don't get what some of the people and
then and then there's this large group
of people that are just kind of afraid
to say anything because they'll get
attacked in the way that that that
conservatives tend to get attacked right
so it's it's it's interesting like we
kind of say you know democrats or
liberals but i don't i don't i think
it's not as big a group as we think i i
used to a few years ago i actually cared
and i think there's a correlation
between when cnn stopped reporting the
news and me not caring what these people
think anymore to a certain degree so i
remember i would i would have cnn on all
the time and they'd be reporting the
news and then they'd have their stupid
anti-trump stuff but i was like you know
whatever and then one day i noticed they
weren't reporting major news it was like
protests in iran or something and so i
changed a channel and then from that
point on more and more you turn on cnn
it would be a panel about trump a panel
about trump and i was like there's no
news here and so it wasn't just this
this it wasn't this uh um
conscious decision where i was like cnn
has lost the plot it was kind of like
i'm looking for the news about this big
event i can't watch cnn
so at that at that point i'm getting i'm
getting to the point where i'm like
people who watch this are detached from
reality but that brought me to a point
where i was like i need to inform people
what's true and what's not true because
cnn is lying and msnbc is lying now i'm
at the point where i'm pretty sure
nobody believes them i mean
the people who do may be too far gone or
lost or whatever they're still worth
talking to and trying to communicate
with hey share this video maybe you can
you can help reach some of them but it's
it's it's funny like when i'm on twitter
and i see some of the things these
people tweet and it's just laughably
false stuff wrong wrong wrong and at a
certain point i'm like
what do you even say to someone who
believes the opposite of reality they
believe you believe the opposite of
reality but clearly we don't
i i don't know and you're not even
you're not even being hyperbolic cnn has
headlines that literally read why
inflation can actually be good for
everyday americans and bad for rich
people so when you have that level of
kind of inversion of of reality of the
truth i mean there used to be a point
where i used to watch them and and i
just recognized this is extremely bad
for your mental health but they used to
be somewhat okay especially when it came
to breaking news and it wasn't that
overt but it came to a point where it's
disgusting it's like it's just like you
take nasty food and you want to throw it
up my mind is wanting to throw up every
time i put on cnn because it's it's just
so disingenuous and it's so
disrespectful for any intelligent person
that's even paying a little bit of
attention to what's going on to
understand that what they're saying is
absolutely delusional and crazy well you
know tier tier points i remember in 2015
i i had this moment i've been watching
china basically for that that was my
focus for years right and i'm watching
the american media and there's by the
way that the media you really prop state
propaganda in china right it's all sent
kind of centralized the talking points
are spread out and it just functions a
certain way there's certain patterns you
watch it for a while you see those
patterns in 2015
i think
our media in america went crazy that's
what i saw like i just said 2015 2015.
this was like basically post kind of
trump announcing his candidacy and this
sort of all these narratives starting to
build and these changes you actually put
your finger on it tim then these
changes in how the programming worked
right and i started watching i was like
wait a sec this is like this is working
like the chinese media i'm not talking
about cnn specifically i'm talking about
broadly you know across many media and
this was the part that was bizarre to me
because over there there's the xinhua
you know propaganda agency basically
controlling everything who's controlling
everything here right but somehow
everybody knew what the what the
narratives were supposed to be it was
the weirdest thing and that's where we
suddenly you know at epoch times became
weird and odd because we were just doing
something different right which was just
true being truth-seeking right
so
something really changed in in 20 2015 i
think it seemed like they wanted hillary
and so bad into the office and then her
email scandal appeared and the media
just kind of this is like okay this is
an opportunity to break one of the
biggest stories of the 21st century this
is huge hillary clinton
10 000 plus emails of her working with
sydney blumenthal to get us into libya
like so much incriminating and it was
like silence because uh and it was
silence and it was like a coordinated
silence i i i sense the two i just
didn't realize i didn't see the
correlation between that and chinese
state propaganda what do you think it's
like the council on foreign relations is
related to coordinating like
at t owns cnn so like at what point are
these corporations coming up to like a
group of like six dudes getting together
and being like i'm gonna have my media
organizations run this story on tuesday
like well we'll do it on wednesday well
they they had something called the
journo list
so it's journal dash out list
and i was actually on some of these
things these were facebook communities
and email groups where all of the new
york media would be in an email chain
or a
like a forum
someone would post news they would all
see it and then everyone would write it
so this created this weird narrative
collusion i actually think people
underestimate how much this turned media
into
rage bait garbage nonsense and polled
the media class outside of america
so when you have people
who only get their news from each other
they're sitting in a room talking to
each other i'll tell you this
look at australia got a bunch of really
weird critters over there huh why they
have endemic species because of the
separation of land masses evolution took
a different path there versus another
place that's an easiest way to the
easiest way to understand what happens
to these news organizations you take a
bunch of these journalists separate them
from regular mainstream americans and
put them in a room and they will evolve
their their perspective and narrative
dramatically away
from where regular americans are now all
of a sudden you get moderates voting for
donald trump who are like i think
america should have factories here i
agree with bernie sanders on you're not
not having the borders wide open and
then all of a sudden they're like that's
far right bernie sanders gets swept up
in the same thing it eventually starts
spreading it goes to social media and
then twitter creates they take this
weird mutant
world view
from these newsrooms spread it out all
over twitter and now it's it's starting
to spread everywhere so i've actually
had this this conversation with peter
begosia and one of the guys who did the
one of the people who did the so-called
squared hoax where they made those they
took mineconf and then turned it into a
feminist journal and then it got
submitted and you know whatever
and his argument was all of this stuff
started in the colleges and i disagree
with that i believe it started in media
and social media i certainly believe a
lot of these ideas wokeness critical
race here and all stuff did start in
colleges but my argument is it was only
when social media and these new york
digital uh publishing firms blogs became
prominent that these ideas skyrocketed
in the lexisnexis database appearing in
the new york times and so when people
say yeah but the ideas originated in
universities i say a lot of ideas are in
universities but this is the only one
that expanded out of it so when you can
highlight a handful of academics with
crazy ideas well there's probably 3 000
more academics with crazy ideas that are
not cultural you know uh marxism or
whatever
but
when you get these people at at big tech
firms on these journalist forums who are
using social media algorithms to uh pump
out as many keywords as possible you get
this warped broken cult and it's
expanding
and the crazy thing is
back in 2012 2013 when we started seeing
gamergate start
so many people thought these were just
creepy weirdos
now we we did a member segment the other
day about tulpas and mind alters
people who are have create they're
suffering from some kind of social
psychosis
so these are people who believe they
have multiple people in their heads
and they make tick-tock videos where
they're like one girl's like i am a doll
i forget to breathe and like these
really weird behaviors
they are it's a social contagion that's
emerging from this and we're watching it
happen in real time that's not out of
universities that's from what the media
is doing and and journalists are wrapped
up in it all the same so you're saying
the chinese top down was it this what'd
you call the xinhua xinhua organization
is coordinating the media that you think
that there's more of an emergent
phenomenon as well where like people are
saying hey that worked on on cnn let's
run it on fox hey that worked on msnbc
let's run it
although there might be a group of like
top-down oligarchs also doing it we
don't have any evidence that was my
conclusion well i think there's certain
opinion leaders okay definitely there's
def i mean you know there was a time
when you know basically the new york
times
set the the news agenda for the day and
everyone just looked at it in the new
york times i mean talk to anyone that
worked in those newsrooms they were
aware of the fact that that was their
job and that was their their their right
you know to to kind of do that right of
course that the the whole sort of
explosion of blogs and everything took
that away from them or at least to some
extent right
well so so um i have talked about this
quite a bit but i'll just try to make it
quick
when you share an article with you know
kamala harris in the headline people who
are interested in kamala harris are fed
that through the algorithm if you have a
headline that says kamala harris jesse
smallette now you're getting both groups
group x and group y the justice millett
fans and the kamala fans and it becomes
exponential so what happened was in the
in the late 2000s early 2010s
these blogs
mike.com is a great example because they
were pro ron paul initially why well the
ron paul love revolution was very
popular online but what started working
better was anti-police brutality
racism and general wokeness so this is
back in 2010 or 11
they started shifting from a libertarian
internet perspective into wokeness
because when you make a headline that
says like trans women of color fighting
for black lives matter against police
brutality are the strength against white
supremacy or whatever you have all of
those keywords crammed in that headline
facebook feeds it to way more people all
of a sudden now intersectionality
started rising and from that we end up
now in a whole world where our co we
have members of congress who are in this
cult who believe things that quite
literally make no sense i would argue
those who control the algorithms control
the minds of the people and i think
that's very evident with a lot of the
agenda that has been achieved through
manipulation of the perception of
everyone's reality and you could very
easily shape that by showing them
certain events and denying them other
events talking about certain set of
facts denying other certain amount of
facts having these echo chambers that
constantly regurgitate the same amount
of news to people so they double down
triple down on their political positions
but i wanted to ask you uh yan
specifically there's a lot of people
talking about what's happening now in
reference to the cultural revolution in
china do you think that's a fair
accurate depiction and do you have any
examples of how that might be uh related
oh no absolutely and that's a fantastic
question i've had a number of people on
the show on american thought leaders
talking about this specifically
one woman named shivan fleet so she kind
of became into prominence in loudoun
county she was one of those parents that
came up and spoke and said i was
actually part of the cultural revolution
i was there
right and and so she it's actually a
really thoughtful interview right
because you know because people will say
well there isn't you know mass killings
or something like that well that's
that's true
right but
the way that language was manipulated
right the way that uh the basically the
way the censorship works there's there's
a whole series of i guess um
these the kind of cultural elements
right that aren't that don't have to do
with the actual compelling people to
behave a particular way everyone being
afraid if i don't join this at this this
sort of performance art this
performative behavior right you know
when i look at those looked at those
tweets earlier i whenever i see that
stuff i think you know these people are
basically virtue signaling to their
base so to speak yes i'm on board with
you that's really what it says it's not
really saying i i think this is true or
something like that and this is all very
much exactly from the cultural
revolution this is what shivan fleet
talked about and what about the
releasing of criminals was that
something that occurred in during the
communist takeover ah no so absolutely
so it's you know we have a we have a
series that it's actually very
interesting called the nine commentaries
on the communist party right and it was
this was written by chine our chinese
edition for chinese millions of chinese
have read it it's a true history of
communism in china one of the chapters
that i never there's a better
translation but originally it was kind
of translated in the first version i i
saw as we were editing it unleashing the
scum of society okay
and actually this is what people do in
the communist system they take the
people who have you know or cluster b
psychopaths all this kind of stuff and
you let them loose on society because
those are that you basically let them
do their thing and create the chaos
right and sort of break the system so
that you can recreate your utopia after
it's just part of the game and if you're
a capitalist or a landowner or a
business owner they literally put you in
the middle of the square start shaving
your head embarrassing you and try to
emasculate you and dehumanize you in
front of everyone one of the scariest
parallels when it comes to the cultural
revolution that i see now is the
centralization of power the
centralization of our economy and the
pure mismanagement of just the food
industry and the trade industry and i
think there's a lot of parallels right
now when it comes to the centralization
of that here in the united states
scientism and scientism like this idea
that there's the science here's the
perspective like science is not one
perspective it never was never will be
right but that's how it's playing out
here that's crazy right
the trope in our media is typically that
doing something for science was viewed
as like a negative
you know there'd be like a mad scientist
and he'd be experimenting on someone
like i must do this for science
and it was like a villainous response to
why they must carry it out it was
showing you to be inhuman
now
you have people who come out and say the
science when they really mean the
establishment narrative because this
science is never settled it's the
weirdest thing for them to say that i
mean i'm sure you know
science is dr fauci tim please have a
correction for our tech overlords and
please forgive forgive us fauci
yeah he's not he's a guy and he gets
things wrong a lot but it's just so much
not any i mean you know my background
i'm an evolutionary biologist but that's
my background right like this you can't
say that that's just nothing to do with
science ever right well let's let's
let's let's talk about uh where wokeness
brings us and evolutionary biology i
think will be interesting for this next
conversation uh we have a story from
daily mail
trans-eupan swimmer leah thomas
complains about loss of muscle and
strength through hormone treatment and
says she's nowhere close to her previous
vest says competing on women's team is
fair now i want to say this outright
because i think it's important and i i
think it's something you'll typically
hear from many of the you know
post-liberal disaffected liberals or
whatever and even many conservatives
although not all of them
i i think people should be able to be
happy and free and not disparaged for
you know whatever individual life
choices they want to make so long as not
harming others
this is the instance where um the
transgender sport uh
issue actually does start causing you
know a degree of harm to others so if
those aren't familiar this is about a a
a person who's biologically male who is
transitioning to be a trans woman named
leah thomas
who just broke a record in you know a
swimming competition and defeated the
next runner-up by over 38 seconds which
for people who understand something if
you've ever watched like michael phelps
the olympics that is not just winning
that is like just totally outclassing
and just absolutely demolishing
everyone else
now there's there's a lot of people a
lot of people are bringing this up
in an interview with outkick a sports
website an unnamed athlete from i
believe this is um
what they say upenn
noted that while thomas is already
breaking school and meet records she
soon
soon may be shattering world records
there's a few things we can we can i can
say here just to get started
if you know the left if if their
ideology wins then i think the simple
argument is we as humans have created
these rules for these sporting events
and if we decide to change them then
they change but that ultimately means
there will be no women's sports
or i should say there will be no sports
exclusive to females to use you know
their their their language
or
we uh i suppose that actually i
shouldn't say or that's it that's
literally the outcome if we head in that
direction otherwise we have to say
outright there will be male and female
distinct divisions but uh you mentioned
you're an evolutionary biologist so i
suppose
that's my background i haven't been
doing i haven't done it for 20 years you
know oh yeah but you know you've got uh
some some context to add into this
conversation i suppose yeah
well okay i mean
i
i don't know what else i can say i mean
there's there's there there are very
very clear
i mean this is the this is just the
biologists perspective i think right
there's just very clear biological
differences between men and women that
you can't
get rid of using hormone therapy or
frankly surgery or anything they're
they're foundational differences and i
mean and this i say this with the
greatest respect for people who are men
that want to be women and you know
leave them to doing with to doing that
be free be free but this also means you
have to have to reconcile other people's
rights as well absolutely and i mean
like this this sort of thing right just
on the face of it it it's is it
unsayable that they won because they're
physically male
right someone pulled up the am i is that
okay to say so yes that's an interesting
question you're cancelled how dare you
have gymnastics
what other explanation is there or are
we supposed to believe that somehow this
isn't a factor i mean what they'll what
they'll end up saying is no not because
they're male their genitals had nothing
to do with this it has to do with just
being taller and having longer arms
which is because
which is a tendency towards you know
being male so the way i the way i framed
it on twitter is just look if the
argument is that from the left that
trans women are women
then as far and they say like literally
like indistinguishable well then it's
quite simple
this uh transgender swimmer has proven
women can swim as fast as men true and
that would mean that all the other women
who lost over 38 seconds are just not
trying hard enough
now actually i'll i i'll be reasonable
on this one to a certain degree i
actually believe
that there is a lack of competition in
in some women's sports because there is
a lower level of direct competition so
i've actually seen this in skateboarding
where there there are certain female
skaters i know who are insanely good at
skating and when i watch them compete
they compete like relaxed like they're
not going to push themselves too hard
because they don't have to and it keeps
everything kind of down so one of the
responses i got to this was well this
actually will drive biological females
to push harder and actually break those
records you know but my response to that
is is it going to matter if the record's
already broken by a trans woman and then
they'll never get anywhere near close to
it
somebody pulled up the uh time that this
uh this trans woman the the swimming
times by like different races and found
they were only off by a few seconds even
after a year of of of transition in
which case
yeah it seems like they're still
competing at the male level which
apparently they were really good at in
the first place i don't know is this an
a tired subject because we know it it
keeps happening no it's insane
completely unfair uh there should be a
trans division yes it's if you have a
kid that fails fourth grade ten times
you don't have him compete with fourth
graders when he's 18. come on and and
there's a number of well frankly
feminists that are calling this out
because it's it's destroying the terms
yeah right that that was a really good
point though that's great if there's if
there's somebody who's you know 13 and
they're in eighth grade and they get
held back three years and now they're
16. and i have seen this
i have seen people have been held back
three years you know
now
a 13 year old to a 16 year old is a big
difference and you're gonna you're gonna
make them play basketball against each
other you shouldn't
yeah so i mean it gets to a point where
he's just
mechanically
the sport doesn't function if you if you
imbalance it mechanically with with
artists or or we performers that are too
strong or weak we were talking to we had
jack murphy on
we have them on every other wednesday
but we had him here a while ago
and we and he was talking about how his
kids you know want to be you want they
want to they're athletes and they want
to be at the highest level and and he
was talking about you know his daughter
or whatever and i was just like
i mean the olymp the future of the
olympics is going to be uh trans women
and i'm not saying it'd be disrespectful
to anybody i mean i think it's just
an objective fact this uh this this this
young woman from upenn who spoke out
said
the ag the aggravated teammate also
claimed swimmers have discussed their
frustrations with their coach mike
schner but he quote just really likes
winning i mean if you're somebody who
wants to see your your team winning if
you get compensation based on how well
you do they're gonna be like don't know
don't care we're gonna win
so i suspect what's probably gonna
happen is we're gonna have men's
divisions and we're gonna have subpar
men's divisions uh i suspect that will
be the case because um i feel like the
men who aren't quite as good are gonna
wanna go into trans women's divisions or
into the women's division because it's
gonna be easy i don't think that you
don't think that i do not believe
they're going to be men who are like
i'll take chemicals and alter my entire
life just so i can try and get a career
in a sport i do think there are going to
be guys um who are really who are
moderately good
and eventually want to transition and
then find themselves dominating the
competition
i i think it's a leap a lot of people
have made that argument that men will
chemically castrate themselves to win
basketball i'm like that's nuts
i don't believe that for a second i do
believe there are going to be males who
are trans who are good at sports or at
least you know moderately good or even
leaning on the bad side but still may be
ranking and then when they transition
that'll put them at the higher bracket
of the women's division and i believe
for a lot of reasons that would be
unfair to biological i could see a
psycho that wanted to win so bad that
they just devastate their body
transition it join another league with
this ripped male body into a female
league i mean south park had an episode
about that futurama i was i was eating
dinner the other day and feature there's
a futurama episode where bender gets a
robot sex change so
he he competes in the robot olympics as
a he's male in the women's division and
then wins all the gold medals and then
in order to pass gender testing gets you
know a robot sex change or whatever and
what the interesting thing is this show
i think was made in the early 2000s
all of the characters said it's
disgusting they said it was gross and
disgusting that he was doing it and how
dare he but i think they're referring to
his cheating right you know
but i i i
i think you know i'll agree with you
guys to a certain to a certain extent
that there may be really awful people oh
for sure who will exploit this the
bigger issue i see is that there have
been transgender athletes who have not
undergone any transition right there's
literally like a guy
and one day he just comes to the coach
and says you know you know i'm trans and
then they say okay you're in the women's
division now so that's why they're
trying to set standards for this
they're trying to quantify how it works
but it it doesn't it doesn't but what
can the rules be i mean you there are
the rules that you have is your
testosterone level
i mean that that that's fascinating in
itself it can how can you do that what
kind you know
what this is this is this is a
fundamental human rights question in my
mind i mean these are i think the end
result is that there will fun there will
be functionally no female sporting
events right what about if we have male
female and then genderless
i think that'll work yeah there someone
uh pointed out on twitter they're like
what do you call it then when men and
women on the same team i'm like they're
called mixed teams like they actually
bring this up apparently
there's like some commission or whatever
that oversees the the racing or whatever
said that if this if the individual
who's trans is competing but hasn't been
a year on hormone therapy then the team
is classified as a mixed team and so
they'll race against a com a mixture of
males and females but this team is just
competing against you know straight
females
it's you know what the craziest thing to
me is
there is a transgender scientist who's
also a marathon runner who actually did
a study in a report about male
testosterone about male muscular and
bone density benefits well after
transition who said that
yeah even few years after transition
like the advantages persist this is a
trans athlete saying this
it's strange to me that there are
individuals who don't recognize
that it's unfair you know what i mean
like it's just what you would i mean
they did the study that's fantastic it's
also kind of what you would expect like
you would have to really do the study to
demonstrate that it's not the case right
but that it's fascinating i mean i don't
know i guess this is just another part
of
we have got two distinct world views in
this country
and this one is the left and the right
doesn't see it but all that matters i
guess where the kids go where where the
the next generation will be and i don't
know why why do we make women sports to
begin with was it so that women at a
like a place where they could compete
generally without having a guy like ian
did you know all the games did you know
that there's most sporting events
sporting leagues have no rule barring
women
at all
so uh women have tried out for the nfl
for instance but the closest they ever
get is to being a kicker and there have
been some women who are really really
good kickers but they're just not as
good as the male kids ncaa kickers male
football teams you have a female kicker
i think that's happened in college yeah
there were well there was one woman and
then they lost and apparently the team
cried or something like that i'm i'm not
i'm not trying to be mean i think that's
actually happened yeah they they decided
they wanted to add the first female
kicker and they did and she flubbed
really bad i forgot what it's called
people tried saying it was a squib kick
because she kicked so short they were
like no as a strategy but apparently the
team came out afterwards and they were
like this was brutal to us we've worked
so hard and now we're losing for
politics
so
there's nothing barring women from being
in male teams other than can they win
like can they when they try out do they
succeed so then we create a division
just for females but now we're having
the argument over what is it what does a
woman mean i mean wikipedia defines a
woman as a bi an adult human female but
activists are trying to change those
definitions and alter what these sports
are
did this girl score leah the the girl
from uh score
her time her time was 38 seconds above
apparently it would have ranked her
second or third in the ncaa women's
championships just like
what does that mean like across the
country that was the second and third
highest that sounds that sounds like uh
national so some some guy transitions to
a female and then wins no no no ncaa
it is a male who is transitioning to be
a trans woman a trans woman is different
than a female yes pardon my pardon my
ignorance yeah uh
and then and then ranks at the top
that's like complete insanity it's like
use some common sense if the floor is
muddy
you know stop tracking mud on it and
clean it up this is a a guy that
transitioned to a well actually here
look at this the daily mail actually has
it they say uh how leah times stack up
against her best as a male swimmer in
the 200 meter free will before the
transition was 1 minute 39 seconds and
leah was 1 minute 41 seconds and the nc
double uh double a is 139.10 in the 500
meter free it was four minutes 18.
for leah it was four minutes 34. so
that's that's a bit down the nc double a
is 424 and in the
1 650 meter free will got 14 minutes and
54. leah got 50 minutes 59 that's a
whole minute and the ncaa is 15 minutes
so
not like this individuals instantly
become the best but certainly one of
them i i don't know i i i think look i i
want to this this has been circulating
this is an old story not not this one
particular but the story that's
happening around someone who is male you
know we had joe rogan talk about this
almost 10 years ago i think it was with
fallon fox right
as far as i can tell if that's the case
it's happening it's done this is the
norm it's the combat that's happening
the combat sports is when it goes too
far uh if you have a man that
transitions to a female or a woman uh
human female whatever it's called i'm
not sure if transitions and then beats
the hell out of a guy or a girl
breaks her face like falling i think
they didn't even know she was had
transition no one had told them that uh
fallon fox was that's that's now if you
want to do a non-combat sport and be
like hey i hit the ball farther than you
i used to be a guy but so what that's
dirty politics to me but
when you're hurting women when you're
when women are getting their faces
broken by people that used to be male
and have a lot of testosterone and final
final thought you know because i think
it's it's crazy that we've talked about
the story for so long and just here it
is it's normal now my final thought i
guess is like shouldn't they just have
an open division where
anyone can choose to compete well let's
do this let's shift to uh foreign policy
a hard segue because um surprisingly
this story wasn't our lead from the
daily caller
biden admin plans on advising ukraine to
hand over territory to russia this is an
effective surrender
of
the conflict with russia in in ukraine
and i couldn't believe it when i read
this because the ap's headline i i
wonder if the daily caller has the link
to the associated press article the ap's
headline
did not actually i think we could pull
it up let's see what they have the
headline is biden assures ukraine's
leader of u.s support to deter russia
that's their headline and everybody sees
that they're like okay sounds like we're
good in eastern europe right and then
you scroll down in the article and it
says administration officials have
suggested that the u.s will press
ukraine to formally seed a measure of
autonomy within its eastern donbass
region which is now under de facto
control by russian-backed separatists
who rose up against kiev in 2014. so
there is a group in eastern ukraine that
are backed by the russians armed by the
russians that
view themselves as completely separate
want to join russia and biden's response
to the build-up of troops by russia is
let him have it
that's crazy to me now i want to stress
this point
if this avoids u.s or eu conflict in the
region in a ground war probably a good
thing but i suppose there's a line i
don't know where it is i agree with
tucker we shouldn't care about ukraine's
borders over our southern border which
is porous and busted
but i'm worried about another
afghanistan situation where joe biden is
sitting there in the command seat and
then vladimir putin racks up 90 000
troops and biden goes
ukraine just just give it to him just
just just just give him the territory
and it's like here we go again could
there be a better way look under trump
this stuff wasn't happening what did
trump do he sold weapons to ukraine and
putin backed off
he
putin takes uh crimea trump gets elected
putin backs off biden gets in putin
comes back and says i take
yeah i don't think biden's calling the
shots here um i i think there's um i
think putin's got compromise i think
there's a long geopolitical
neoconservative
pentagon establishment that does call
the shots and there's a lot of things
happening behind the scenes i wouldn't
be surprised if there's a trade-off here
if there's a bigger deal here um you
know the united states did give ukraine
2.5 billion dollars of of weaponry uh
they have been very active in the region
they have had success turning ukraine
that had its fear of influence with
russia towards the european union so
this is a very complex picture it's
going to be interesting to see how it
unfolds from here obviously i prefer
diplomacy over hot war and i think we
should avoid hot war no matter what i
think the larger geopolitical no matter
what your uh well you know what i mean i
i think
we don't need neoconservatives in charge
threatening nuclear war and we have that
right now a part of the us government
threatening the russian government um i
don't think that helps the situation at
all so i think diplomacy is key here and
i think all of america's foreign policy
especially the way it's been run under
trump and now biden is shooting itself
on the foot and totally
counterproductive and also holds europe
in jeopardy since of course europe also
depends on a lot of russian oil and
energy that's being shipped towards it
right now so there's a lot of at stake
here um i still want to see the full
picture before jumping the gun and
understanding what's really happening
here what about you i i think this is a
your point is really really well taken
because there's there's all these
complex pieces there's also the piece of
like what are you know the central
european countries like poland you know
we were both you know both polish roots
what are they thinking as they're
looking you know poland wants to be this
big um you know basically ally to the us
and the u.s is basically doing things
like
encouraging
giving land to the russians that's like
a huge red flag for the polls i mean
this is the polls have been run
basically the russians have invaded many
times the germans have invaded many
times they're
you know expecting the next time right
well let me ask you guys though is there
is there any circumstance in which you
think it would be good for u.s troops to
be on the ground in ukraine
that's a very hard decision to make here
uh because of all the pieces here i i
would prefer it it doesn't happen i
would prefer diplomacy rule here i i
understand that you said that but my
question is you said you know um what do
you say at all costs or or i avoid war
i think we should avoid war at all costs
uh so so what if the cost is like uh
you know russia
overtly invades ukraine to kiev and
russian tanks are occupying the capital
of ukraine now i think it's the obvious
thing to point out we are not ukraine we
uh how much of it is our how much of it
is it our business to be like here's a
country that we're sort of friends with
but we're not even not even a part of
the nato alliance
should we intervene
yeah genocide what if the russians went
in and started executing families
children on the street lots of media
coverage of it are we supposed to go and
police the world at this point is the
time done for that i'm tired of putting
our people in harm's way i think there's
ways of appeasing both sides and and
calming the situation down without
reaching to those types of hyperbolic
levels now you made a good point poland
and other european countries are very
set against russia poland even uh is
building a military base called the
trump military base
very close to of course the russian
border um so so obviously there's a lot
of history there there's a lot of
turmoil there's a lot of conflict
there's a lot of bloodshed and it's just
it's just a horrible situation to deal
with that that we should avoid the the
bloodshed to me i'm gonna divert the
question a little bit because i don't i
don't fully know the answer to be
perfectly honest but i what i do know is
that
some like what i believe is that the
russians basically putin they only
really understand strength as a response
and if you don't use that as is a
important tool of your diplomacy and
they are incredibly aware of the fact
that you will use whatever tool you have
if they cross the red line and it's a
real red line then they're going to
abuse that massively and i mean so this
you know this strategy this is what they
used in crimea right they moved
basically it's this kind of like gray
gray zone warfare right where they move
people in it's not really russian
there's kind of these people kind of
take over with the support and then
suddenly hey this is russia right
and so how many times do you let that
happen how do you know you you need to
support your allies right right
and and that's and that's it i mean they
took crimea russia took it everyone you
know a lot of people believe i think
it's fair to say the elections in crimea
were bunk they came and said oh
everybody voted it's fine now crimea is
annexed by russia because russia wants
their warm water port
but
there there are hard questions about war
right and the reason i ask about what
russia is doing and what biden should do
is i agree i don't want ground war
i i think it may if biden is is telling
them look you're going to lose the
eastern front because we want to avoid
war it's like maybe avoiding war is
better and if the people in the eastern
front really do
want to be you know part of russia and
don't they have the the autonomy to
decide where who who they should be
governed by or what country they should
be a part of there's really tough
questions but the reason i ask about you
know war is because right now china's
got the weaker muslim camps and are we
declaring war on china are we going to
be like it's time to storm the beaches
of macau to like make our way to the you
know xinjiang you know region or
whatever
right now in
in you know in the u.s congress there's
were huge efforts being made to water
down the provisions that would actually
hold
uh you know china's activities in
xinjiang to to account you know it's
it's it's it's fascinating so here's
here's this is the question right so i
just i was just uh you know speaking
with uh the former the former head of uh
human rights democracy and labor okay
for the state department under trump
um
uh robert destro so you know there's
probably you could say fairly there's
three genocides happening in china right
now there's the ogre one the uyghur
tribunal just
reinforced that reality basically today
and then there's the the tibetans is the
same model that's been happening for a
long time and and against the falun gong
practitioners as well you know an
attempt to eradicate you know an entire
group not necessarily by killing
everybody that's a later stage of
genocide but but through all sorts of
means including these four
sterilizations um
etc and so on and so forth that's
actually interesting
there's there's this kind of other flip
side they're trying to actually prevent
people from getting sterilized in china
but that's that's a different topic
um well how do you deal this is the
worst thing this is what we agree the
global community the free world agrees
it's the absolute worst thing you can do
it's the worst thing right try to
eradicate entire groups of people china
is doing one for sure
possib probably three
and they they rag on tucker carlson for
saying why do we care about ukraine they
accuse him of defending putin that the
democrats act like vladimir putin is the
most powerful evil on the planet and and
russia's like almost nothing to us at
this point granted they got a lot of
nuclear weapons that i can get but
they've much smaller population and
china's massive and way more powerful
and more dangerous and committing
atrocities
and way more intertwined financially and
that's that's the other very serious
part of the puzzle right well china is
threatening america's hegemony and the
geopolitical picture between russia and
the united states is complicating that
and essentially allowing china to win
because they have russia which is going
to be aligning with them when they are
naturally competitors there's a lot of
thing that divides russia and china and
if geopolitically the united states
played their cards differently they
could have another strategic
ally in the region against their number
one a lying foe the number one
competitor uh that that most likely is
going to create the tasidius trap which
we talk about on the show a lot when
through cities yeah when an emerging
power threatens our current power
there's a high likelihood of war of
conflict so i think on the geopolitical
scale that's a lot more important
especially with the picture of taiwan um
which the united states you know
geopolitically is kind of ignoring
almost outright
so to see this russian perspective
there's a way that there there should be
negotiations we shouldn't just give
anything up we should be uh tough we
should con you know uh
control our interests but we have to
also ask ourselves what were the
russians and chinese saying when the
united states was invading iraq when the
united states was invading afghanistan
were they saying hey if they attacked
this country this sovereign country that
had nothing to do with 9 11 like iraq
are we going to defend them when they're
doing a genocide on on their people
that's and again i'm not making those
arguments but those were the arguments
and conversations that happened in their
countries and we have to understand that
those arguments if we're going to come
to a table to try to understand this
larger world picture uh that's unfolding
right now that's extremely complicated
that's a great point yeah the whole
the united states took iraq china is
going to take taiwan russia takes
crime here so the whole idea of the
genocide convention right like i'm not a
fan of countries going out nation
building you know taking over areas us
any any kind of this is this is not this
is not good behavior
genocide is one of these things the
reason the genocide convention exists is
because there was a very serious
genocide the holocaust
right and people said
we we can't allow this to happen this is
something that we actually everybody
needs to get involved in
internationally when we see this
happening we really need to act right
because this is the worst thing humans
do to each other
right yeah
yeah there was uh we we talked about a
bit there was a post um james lindsay
made about what what separates a
concentration camp from normal forms of
imprisonment and they said it's when
someone is detained without due process
when they're taken from their home and
putting a camp without due process
exactly right the escalation on the
other hand is is you know
it depends right so that that's the idea
about what happened in in germany was
they were going and taking people and
then sending these camps which is
happening in a lot of different parts of
the world and it's not just china also a
lot of people you know a lot of the
bigger political uh establishment in
russia is saying well the united states
got libya they got syria they're
creating a domestic conflict in yemen
they're they they had their sphere of
influence in iraq and afghanistan
they're getting theirs we should get
ours so that's the type of conversations
that they're having and i i think again
there's a lot of chess pieces on the
table but we have to reassess what we
know what we're told because there's a
totally different picture that we're not
seeing that we should see let's let's
bring it all together you know we talked
about the social issues in that in the
united states um which led to you know a
lot of questions about black lives
matter and wokeness and trans issues and
then we have what's going on with the
geopolitical conflicts we have this
story from timcast.com
men prevented from getting vasectomies
under china's new family planning
policies china is trying to stave off a
population crisis caused by its
declining fertility rates
with over 1.4 billion people the decline
could create a crisis as the population
ages and is not replaced the densely
populated nation could run out of
workers which would cause severe
economic consequences this is
fascinating in the united states we have
no such effort we have the opposite
they're telling people to not have kids
they're saying if you want to save the
environment have no kids i've been
saying for a while it really feels like
there is a an effort from global elites
to convince americans to burn down their
own country
china will keep growing and perhaps it's
because they are scared of thucydides
trap that when a rising economic power
reaches the level of us of the sitting
economic power war becomes extremely
likely it feels like there are powerful
interests that are just saying look
either the world implodes from a great
conflict between two superpowers or we
let america down slowly and let them
spiral out of control then and then
china takes over do you really want the
model where that runs three genocides at
the same time and has a and has a murder
for budding murder for organs industry
that's uh you know state-sanctioned yeah
you want that model across the world no
but i'll tell you this the the uh
political establishment here in the us
does the idea that they with absolute
authority never have to worry about an
election again that they can just go in
with an with an iron fist and a rubber
stamp and wipe your house off the map to
build a highway they would love it
that's a very disturbing thought
and that's and that's what they do in
china that that's that's exactly what
they do in china that's exactly what
they can do and they do do
they do do
and they will uh uh and if we if we
don't stand up and we don't speak out
and we don't support what we believe in
uh the democrats and the and the neocons
the yield libs and the neocons will do
do here as well
and all over our constitution
and it is funny but it's true though i
mean
we
we've talked to several people who have
you know um they cover chinese issues
you know related to like foreign policy
and they talk about what what the
chinese communist party does and we're
told that there was a period where you
know democratic establishment
politicians saw what they do in china
how they one day can walk up to a group
of houses and say destroy it all and
throw those people in the gutter in the
gutter and then we're gonna build a
government facility here and they can do
it like that or or the state exactly
what they did to build the stadiums for
the 2008 olympics they took the water
away right
did they take the water from like
farmers and peasants they they at the
every level of you know basically
disenfranchisement taking people's homes
away without any due process to use that
term used earlier
um it just they and frankly raised a lot
of history actually you know
these hutong areas and so forth this is
also why uh justin trudeau says that he
looked up to china's basic dictatorship
describing their kind of economic power
and centralization which allows them to
control the markets whichever way they
want uh and it doesn't surprise me that
someone like justin trudeau made those
statements i want to comment so this
about this control right why why do they
have the situation with the you know
sort of preventing vasectomies now right
china one of china's most massive
problems is this demographic cap that
they created through these crazy control
policies the one child policy right so
they i mean this is a massive problem
for them they're not going to solve it
by force preventing people from getting
vasectomies they don't actually have no
one this is one thing that i've never
heard any remotely credible solution to
this
other than perhaps i mean immigration
might be the solution it but no one
wants to go live in a dictatorship that
that does what it does well china
doesn't allow immigration their their
their borders are almost predominantly
closed they're very nationalistic and
they treat outsiders uh according to
many accounts uh very wrong to say
one of the biggest detriments to the
woke left is that if they are
unsuccessful in their attempts to get
their ideology in schools they will
eventually cease to exist and the math
is actually really simple i've actually
covered this it's very interesting there
is a pew research poll showing that
generation z is slightly more
conservative than millennials but still
very progressive in the same way
millennials are just leaning a little
bit and a lot of people assumed this
meant that generation z was like waking
up they were realizing but it's not true
what we're actually seeing is
the ramification of
of replacement levels from the early
2000s so if you go back to the early
2000s you'd see many studies show
liberals were having something like 1.5
kids on average and conservatives were
having 2.01 which meant conservatives
are replacing themselves and liberals
weren't fast forward 20 years what do
you get you get 20 year olds voting
and they lean a little bit more right
not because they believe what
conservatives believe but just because
there are more conservative gen z than
there are liberal ones that will persist
but
as many people have pointed out
progressives and leftists don't have
kids they have yours
so if they cannot get their ideology in
schools then we're looking at 20 40
years two more cycles in the two more
generations and the united states
becomes overwhelmingly conservative so
this is why they hate first of all the
idea of school choice but the other
thing i was going to ask you yan because
you're somewhat the authority is what on
earth was china thinking how can you not
look at for example a one-child policy
and a country where they kill millions
upon millions of little girls before
birth after birth doesn't matter to them
and think this will be fine in the long
term i don't understand their thinking
well and you know that's just just to
highlight that point there's this crazy
situation in china where there's just
all these males that can't find
someone to be with right
yeah yeah like like it you know go ahead
you think that's what they were going
for because that was something i noticed
a long time ago if i was like if you
have a bunch of disenfranchised lonely
single young men what are they going to
want to do oh right go to war exactly
and i was like is this this is the
strategy i think i think they simply
imagine and this is the problem these
you know command top control social
sort of utopian
vision control systems right you don't
there's there's all sorts of collateral
damage that you can create i don't think
they thought it through i'll be
perfectly honest i really don't think
they thought through it all they just
thought hey we want to limit the
population size this is great let's do
it i i i disagree a little bit i think
uh ladies and something with war
because why would they tell these men
who can't find lovers not to get
vasectomies right because they don't
know who's going to survive and if
random guys are going out saying well i
can't find a mate i'm going to get you
know my balls chopped off anyway then
what happens when many people go to war
and the ones who remain are unable to
have children so they're basically
saying no no everybody remained fertile
and then when 30 of you die in the
conflict of the united states through
cities trap then all right we'll we'll
figure out who then can have kids well
there's a big population crisis in china
the the chinese government has also been
caught building databases of women and
their fertility ranking wow um and and
we have to understand that this one
child policy was cheered on by a lot of
internationalists by a lot of globalists
including the founder of cnn ted turner
that openly said that this was a great
plan this is awesome this is what the
world should be implementing the people
who opened up china to the world henry
kissinger david rockefeller the ones
that took american jobs and sent them
overseas for cheap slave labor those are
the individuals that also cheered on
those policies because they were also
big proponents of population control and
eugenics
and we see similar epithets by the world
economic forum we see similar epithets
uh said by individuals like you know i
have to say it bill gates and other
individuals
but but those policies i wouldn't be
surprised were made as a part of a deal
according to my own kind of perspective
and opinion saying hey we're going to
give you all these jobs we're going to
give you all these corporations coming
to you but you need to implement the
policies that we want you to implement
top down control spying on citizens
social credit score and a system where
of course we regulate and control the
population and almost every aspect to me
china is the globalist experiment and
now china's saying hey we need more
people we're dealing with a population
uh uh uh crisis here and we need to take
action and they are taking very
strong actions for that when when it
comes to the fertility question you know
it just just occurred to me there is
this you know you're probably aware of
this this sort of dramatic drop in male
fertility certainly in the us they've
done you know extensive studies but it's
abroad they think
it's unclear what the mechanism is they
think it's some basically chemicals in
the system now china is the most
polluted country right they basically
have very very limited pollution
controls
there's all sorts of you know basically
human human devastation as a result of
that i wonder if there isn't also a
fertility crisis even worse than there
is here in the us and in in the free
world so to speak you ever see the
buzzfeed video from the try guys
oh yeah so these were four guys it was
buzzfeed right yeah i think so and these
four guys young millennial men decide to
get their testosterone levels checked
and i don't think they did research into
this because when they went and did and
then published the results the
testosterone was comparable to to that
of like 80 year old men
it was bad it was bad so i mean these
guys but then all just all of them had
this
yeah and all their testosterone was way
below average
and they're what they're in their 20s or
something yeah i think so that's that's
at their prime and these guys test run
was comparable to like elderly men but
this wasn't something of the fact that
they were hanging out with each other or
something like that i don't know
i'm just saying i think i think we're
seeing something with uh with the
infantilization of the millennial
generation and uh potentially gen z you
know i've long thought about this how um
you know i read a lot about how dogs
became domesticated and how they were
wolves
and dogs are effectively permanent
puppies they retain the behaviors of
puppies the love the desire but they
don't ever develop the alpha independent
and controlling and dominant nature of
the wolf
this was bred out of them by humans who
didn't want that the humans wanted to be
in charge so
long story short when wolves started
scavenging the refuse of human camps the
wolves that were more tolerant and had
the right behaviors were tolerated by
the humans and the humans who were more
tolerant of the wolves had a hunting
partner with with wolves and then proto
dogs but eventually this artificial
selection breeds out or i guess
technically natural selection at this
point because it wasn't planned
bred out the aggressive wolf behaviors
and then what ends up happening is proto
dogs were like permanent wolf puppies
and so i see something similar in where
we're going now with humans we are
becoming childlike humans in their in
their uh mid-20s have never had a job
before they're uh they're they're
they're 35 year old men hosting podcasts
who have no kids and aren't married
but it's true
you know my dad well i think he was 27
he had two kids
and uh i think the average age of a
woman have a child even today is still
24 but we're seeing that pushing back i
think now among like you know
millennials that's getting way lower
that that that average still comes from
the older generation that when they're
asked when was the how old were you when
you had your first kid then like 24 so
that factors in it's probably 21. but
it's so you know it's a lot of this is
really social conditioning i mean it
isn't the thing that you should do to
have lots of kids i mean it is in
hasidic communities for example like my
brother-in-law you know he has he has
five kids his his uh daughter
married into a family of 13. this is
just what you do in
orthodox jewish communities but you
don't do it in you know mainstream
american society in fact it's kind of
odd to have a lot of kids right this is
why the future is conservative and
religious
because um there's there's two big
factors here and this and this is again
if the leftists fail in schools their
ideology will will age out with them
conservatives are substantially less
likely to advocate or have abortions and
they're also substantially more likely
to have children in the first place
another thing we should really consider
here is that china is dealing with the
population crisis and they're deciding
to take executive centralized action on
it the united states and the west is
also dealing with the population crisis
and we're encouraging it and saying this
is great we need to save the environment
we need to stop making children and we
even have elon musk came out just a few
days ago and said civilization is going
to crumble if people don't have more
children and i i believe his warnings
are uh warranted i think they're true i
mean how how can how can this not be
true right i mean unless we're talking
about some sort of weird meta
transhuman
future which is we are yeah
let me just highlight the article luke
mentioned real quick from cnbc elon musk
says civilization is going to crumble if
people don't have more children the tech
billionaire said low and rapidly
declining birth rates are one of the
biggest risks to civilization
i wanna i wanna i wanna uh i can sort of
provide some evidence to elon musk's
claim there was a ted talk by a guy who
tried to make his own toaster from
scratch
how much does a toaster cost at walmart
twenty bucks ten bucks ten
yeah it's really cheap really the other
day yeah i just assumed inflation would
yeah no nickname yeah ten bucks yeah
that that means if you work at
mcdonald's on average depending on which
city you work in it's probably gonna
take about an hour hour and a half to
get a toaster so this guy decided to
make a toaster himself it's impossible
he discovered it was not possible why he
could not synthesize plastics
he could make everything else he could
you could mine the oar he could smelt it
he could make the wiring he could make
all of that stuff the control mechanisms
but to get the plastic for the outside
of the toaster he had to mine the
plastic which effectively proves it
couldn't be done
and the reason i bring this up in
regards to elon musk is it shows the
level of specialization among humans has
grown so intense that no single person
can make a thing there's a um
i'm i'm forgetting who wrote the book so
forgive me what's it called it's um oh
uh julie borowski i think oh yeah was
she what did she write no one knows how
to make a pizza is that hers i think
that was her yeah i hope i'm getting the
person right because if someone else is
mad at me sorry but uh the point of the
book was that
cheese pepperoni tomatoes sauce the
bread
no one person can make all of these
things for the most part a pizza is not
that hard to make what elon musk is
basically saying is
and and this is just one part of it
with a declining birth rate one day
we're going to be like hey who's who's
who there's no food at the supermarket
oh well no one's driving trucks anymore
well who's why not because there's no
one to drive trucks anymore well what
are people doing
people are doing other jobs right now
the unemployment the the amount of
people who aren't working is half the so
let me phrase it better there is twice
as many job openings as people without
work the problem is the people without
work don't have the specialty for those
jobs
this is what elon musk is talking about
we need specialties and specialists to
advance technology and if we don't it
doesn't happen
he's right too and elon musk is the one
who says if you want more things you
have to make things which sounds very
profound but when you talk to people who
truly believe that milk grows out of
store shelves you realize that we might
have a problem with conceptualizing
where they think they do come from they
do they do what they do during the the
primary
in in 2019 with andrew yang i had people
tweeting at me like i was like if people
aren't no no i'm sorry this was uh i
think it was last year it was 2020 and i
was like if people aren't working to
make milk where will they get milk and
they're like what do you mean the store
and i was like where do you think the
milk comes from at the store and they're
like what are you talking about the
store has milk and i was like wow wow
these people don't understand the
concept of the supply chain i'm not
saying everybody i'm not saying any
particular group of people i'm saying
there are people who really don't get it
well we have been really really lucky
our society is super specialized and we
don't have to like spend all day farming
and doing all this other stuff but it
makes us very spoiled it very makes us
very insular we don't realize everything
that goes into bringing us for example
our pizza or our pencil or milk on the
store shelves and it weakens us and i
think that that might even be a
component to men becoming weaker as well
and people not even being interested in
having kids like i wonder if it's like a
hugely overarching societal problem of
ease that's just what i came up with
well there's there's that aspect there's
diet there's chemicals there's also the
lowering of the iq of children because
of lead and other poisons in our
environment there's there's a lot of
things that attributes to it to the
indoctrination centers that people call
schools there's there's so many
different things that contribute to the
destruction of the future of the united
states that it's
almost as if it's being done
deliberately to this point especially
financially economically if you look at
what's happening here uh we are headed
towards an utter disaster we are falling
off the cliff very soon i think we're
already off the cliff but we're still in
the moment where we think it's fun it's
not uh there's going to be where
i think we're moments away from
realizing holy crap there's a lot of
consequences for our
uh
deliberate actions that have put us on
this trajectory towards a wall that's
that's all the way down let me just i'll
just add one thing too it's uh like we
drove off the edge of the of the cliffs
yeah we're flying through the air and
we're like going we people are all
cheering and screaming and there's a few
of us jim cramer's like the economy's
doing better than ever and there's and
there's a few people in the car going
guys guys we're actually going to start
falling down the cliff into that rocky
crevasse and then cnn you got oliver
darcy or wherever he's in the car with
us he goes actually falling into the
cross is a good thing
uh we can make a train fly that's what
i'm focusing on right now so get on
board good luck and yeah it's going to
take some some effort but it's good what
do you think john m well i would you
know you made me think of modern
monetary policy you know like you can
just we can we can we can we can uh
spend our way out of it right
sure yeah oh yeah that works great for
uh families and
i i have to believe that they're like
high level banker and financial dudes
that are like working around the federal
reserve
and they're printing all of this money
they're well it's digital so they're
typing all this money and then as soon
as the like some of these bankers get
the money they immediately convert it
into something else they're like send
the money and then they're buying crypto
they're buying silver they're buying
gold they're buying land and they're
buying it in other countries yes because
i'll tell you this man
if you if look right
what a bitcoin fell from like 60 was at
68 and it fell to like 43 it's the
holidays so a lot of people expected
this if you know what's going on with
crypto
but even now
you know everyone's i had people asking
me like oh was w were you talking all
this good stuff about crypto saying it
was going to be all big and i'm like
dude i bought it at like a couple grand
you know i'm like of course it drops
down but i'm i'm i'm happy
you know
when when everything started getting bad
you know around last year i started
saying i didn't want to be holding onto
us dollars and so i decided not to i
decided to just you know try and invest
in the company as much as i can get the
equipment the company needs as fast as
possible
prices have gone way up we have a guitar
because we're recording a bunch of new
music and we got pete parata formerly of
the offspring who's working with us big
fan awesome super excited and um i've
got a standard uh mexican telecaster
it's a guitar
and
i bought that thing for like 450 bucks
brand new
and now i have another standard uh
mexican tele and it was twice the price
and it's only been i think like four or
five years or whatever the price has
doubled i went to a guitar store and the
guy told me that if you order a guitar
today it's going to take you uh 18
months or whatever to get it
it's becoming harder and harder to get
things and people are are not realizing
it because it's a ripple effect
there there was some leftists who
tweeted like this is a luxury problem
remember who it was she was like all the
rich people are just complaining because
their luxuries are more expensive it's
like yo milk is up but
yeah are you listening to the warnings
so we're at the industry we're at an
industry professional level it's really
difficult to get things like the
internet it's really difficult to get
specialty equipment for it it's
ridiculously expensive because we're
trying to get the best of the best to
run a business so we are seeing the
problems we're trying to get more space
built at the studio instead we have to
get a different studio we can't move the
hvac because the the materials we need
for it aren't being shipped in they
don't exist is a regular person
complaining about whether they can get
hvac materials no but what happens next
it's a ripple effect we got a bunch of
articles popping up saying next year
sticker shock is going to cause the an
apocalypse for the for for middle class
workers when they when they see the
price jump january 1st i think it is
general mills raising the price on all
cereals by 20
that means if you're like
i got a budget for cereal box of seals
for my kids is five bucks now it's gonna
be six bucks your budget's all off and
that may be one dollar right there but
it adds up across the board because it's
to affect the grains are going to affect
everything
same with gas i opened up a bag of chips
last night and it was like a third of a
bag of chips worth of chips it was so
sad
yeah so much empty space in that bag
shrink flour
people are posting photos of when they
like i bought a box of waffles then came
back and the box is tiny yeah to be fair
though americans eat way too much true
yeah we went when we were in texas we
went to a diner and the plate they gave
me was like a trough i was like i don't
i don't i can't eat this you know i love
it i i have to bring it home every time
every time i go out in any kind of
restaurant i'm like give me just give me
it to go anyway i'm going to take it
home eat it later i hate wasting food
yeah and thanks to your point you know
this is one of the craziest things i'm
trying to wrap my head around you know
because a lot of these the lockdown
policies that that we experienced well
all over the world but certainly here in
america right that led to a lot of
obesity i mean if the numbers are
actually astounding i don't have them in
front of me but
but like and that is actually the thing
aside from age and having some
comorbidities that that actually makes
you way more susceptible to covet
that's that's nuts yeah is it like um
confirmed that it looks like keto
fat cells
is that like an official scientific
narrative now
i just saw that and i just saw that
headline i haven't read the article yet
i i have to look at it looks i mean you
read something like that and you're like
i think i'm gonna take a really close
look at this before i just accept it
there's an article from last year where
they said that they tested uh ice cream
tested positive for covid in china and
they had a recall this ice cream it was
in the ice cream so i thought okay maybe
it lives in animal fat
um but i've never seen another article
about it never saw it confirmed or
denied it just appeared in newsweek and
then it was gone i'd say that even if it
doesn't live in fat cells it's probable
that obesity weakens the immune system
enough in every way that it's enough but
they're trying to figure out why they're
trying to figure out why i will i will
just say sugar is the devil that's right
and get it out of there yep you don't
need it anymore it's bad
i'm doing keto right now too man
yeah i'm trying to trying to lose a
little bit i just got i got hit with the
sugar in here a little bit but you know
what you know what you know well i had
there was nothing there was nothing to
it for me i i didn't care i was i was
skating you know every day
and then one day i just accidentally
only ate you know high fat meat and
cheese had like avocados for breakfast
and then i had heavy cream in my coffee
and then i was like i just keep doing it
whatever and then i ended up losing a
bunch of weight yeah and i've just been
feeling better and better see i can't do
the diets where you're like just do this
much or to eat less or like this is
really simple no carbs that's easy i can
do that right
it's not no carbs yeah yeah yeah it's
very yeah no of course of course because
it you'd be insane also if vegetables if
someone was a conspiracy theorist and if
there were central controllers out there
you know what would be better than
having a disease out there that calls
the population especially the people who
eat the most and the most elderly that
don't work don't produce anything and
don't and you have to give a pension to
what better way to slim the fat
literally and figuratively if you were a
central controller hypothetically uh
theoretically um if you were doing that
it's very cold man well hey
let's let's ask the audience over in the
super chat so if you haven't already
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com we're gonna have a
members-only segment coming up later
tonight it's posted at timcast.com
around 11 or so p.m you'll see it on the
front page so if you want to become a
member you got to go to timcast.com i
stressed that because a few people have
you know made the mistake of signing up
for youtube's membership program which
is very different same yes but let's
read some super chats
all right we got this one from stephen
isaac he says
does this now mean that jesse smallett
has been found guilty of hate crimes in
the heart of maga country oh oh
i don't know if it's a hate crime
because he just lied to the cops
so you know
all right andrew
but he did commit a hate crime against
himself that's right exactly
sorry hopefully he doesn't beat himself
up about it
all right andrew um i'm gonna pronounce
this wrong is it pig chick uh pig zick
he says how is it that tim collects all
these random polls
we're not random i knew tim for like 10
years
longer than that it's actually oh no
it's actually been just about 10 years
yeah crazy wow
all right let's see
dermy wormy says if you guys want great
coverage of the maxwell trial go no
further than good logic on youtube an
actual lawyer going to court to the
courthouse watching the trial and
reporting everything wow that's that's
great we are in contact um oh are we we
are but as soon
yeah and i think for a lot of this stuff
we should we're talking with like steve
bannon we're going to do special
interviews for the website just so that
we can have more in-depth sit-down
conversations that are very hyper
focused and specific not like a podcast
with multiple new subjects and
off-the-cuff conversation so it'll be
great to have like a direct
breaking down of like the maxwell trial
and epson and all that stuff
all right fidel leblanc says watched
that yuri besmanov ideological
subversion video again today and if you
just replace soviets with ccp it's 100
accurate today crazy
wow
mark va 71 euphoric break says i've been
keto nearly nine years you're looking
great tim keep it up thank you good sir
we had um last time we had ariel
scarcella on she's a good friend she's a
youtuber she was like she's like wow tim
you're looking you're really different
you're looking good and i was like what
does that mean and she was like i'm
complimenting you and i was like no i
know but like like specifically like
because i've been eating i've been doing
keto the my first uh introduction with
the keto stuff was back when it was a
conspiracy theory and all the media was
saying it was dangerous and not to do it
i knew this guy who would drink a glass
of heavy whipping cream for breakfast
i can't do that right that's crazy i
definitely put heavy whipping cream in
my coffee that's about it but this goo
this dude he would pour a glass of it
and drink it and be like you know high
fat diet and idea yeah your body starts
to swell it's
ripped oh wow he was crazy ripped yeah
man i was like i don't know about all
that and then like he had bacon for
lunch or something well good for him
deliopolis says it's easy for us to
laugh at jesse now but we shouldn't lose
sight of the fact his ruse if he pulled
it off could have easily gotten people
killed
yeah and it it
it sowed so much hate and animosity and
anger in this country that dude is evil
well and then there's and there's still
people that believe it's true and that's
the thing that that that's crazy about
these things right like
that the callous nature of their of how
they
it's crazy man
are these people sociopaths
jesse is yeah i think so
jesse jesse he strikes me as really
really dumb like not smart i look at him
he looks normal and i've never talked to
him or even listen to an interview with
them but after listening to this i think
like you know what that's kind of
probably dumb you know you know what it
is they need to if the problem is he's
in disguise he by shaving off his
mustache because if he didn't he would
have been sitting in court twirling it
and they would have that the jury would
have been like oh we can see it right
now
you know but he's trying to hide all six
all right spork witch says not quite
right luke
fox recused herself then had her office
and her subordinates which still report
to her handling everything it was only
after it was taken away from her office
entirely as it should have been that
something was done
she didn't recuse herself
she technically did by saying she well
i would say this she literally didn't
recuse herself she just went i'm
recusing myself and then everyone was
like but you literally did not formally
recuse yourself because your office is
still working on it and she was like
shut up and she was putting pressure on
the office and saying that the charges
were uh were
there was too much charges
yep
all right
mcsquared says that the jesse wasn't
worth the squeeze for this smoolier
but once he's sentenced his milkshake
will bring all the boys to the yard keep
up the great work tim and crew you're an
inspiration
kenneth bedwell says luke and jan will
you inform tim about n chamberlain
austria 412 1938 czechoslovakia in 1938
and lead to poland uh and led to poland
being erased for 65 years no appeasement
yeah well so this is i was thinking
about this but this is a you know this
is kind of a different topic
uh
where we jump to a different topic i
mean in a nutshell right when people are
annexing land right i.e
nazi germany
and nothing happens that just this is
the thing like the these authoritarian
leaders all they know is
for force and strength and if you don't
respond with strength they're going to
take more it's just it's just i don't
know if it's human nature i don't know
what it is but this just you know
history is rife with this reality we're
talking about end chamberlain as neville
chamberlain the british prime minister
during nazi germany's rise to power he's
in our time and and hitler wanted to
annex was it czechoslovakia
poland in the united kingdom had an
alliance and a defense pact so if poland
was attacked the united kingdom said
that they would come in and defend
poland and they never did
oh yeah yep and then neville was like
peace in our time yeah teasing hitler
and then eventually hitler was like okay
now he sends a blitzkrieg and then they
start bombing
oh no what's happening why is he doing
it germany kept annexing land and then
they were like we'll just give him this
little bit of land and then he'll stop
and he never stopped well history is
also complex there as well because
there's a lot of it that goes even
before that world war one and how
germany had its land taken away so
there's it's it's europe it's filled
with so much history i used to love
traveling there but now it's all fascist
everywhere almost everywhere poland
still is still standing strong somehow a
little bit
but uh all the other places i i just
won't be able to visit in my lifetime
again i can't go to canada unless you
get the vaccine yeah can't go to most
places in europe now yeah
all right jt fire says ian according to
the bible you cannot enter heaven unless
you accept jesus christ as your lord and
savior savior god wants all people to
know all people
i think it's i i i think it's fair to
say maybe i'm wrong i think sheamus
would be a good person ask about this
that's like if you're on your deathbed
and you try to do the death bed
repentance where you're like please
forgive me
pretty sure
god's gonna be like i believe him i
think he's gonna know what's true in
your heart and if you're just saying it
out of desperation it's not gonna fly
right
that always tricked me out like if
hitler right before he blew his brains
out was like
and by the way i accept jesus into my
heart i for i what have i done i've done
so much wrong i'm and i'm repentant and
he really truly was does that mean he's
up there in heaven right now waiting
hitler
if he really was repentant and truly
accepted according to catholicism yes
he's in heaven yes right that to me is
nonsense like a soul someone that does
what he did with that much vitriol is
not gonna have a calm
heavenly soul it's gonna be tortured man
there's a joke that i just read it's an
old one where a politician dies and then
he finds himself at the pearly gates and
saint peter says oh yes you know so
you're a politician right well we have a
new policy here that says you have to
spend one day in hell and then you get
to decide where you want to go and he's
like
no no i don't want to do that why do i
spend a day in hell and it's like it's
just policy and then blink he wakes up
in this luxury suite with you know
beautiful like you know silk sheets and
everything's nice and a
handsome gentleman walks in hands him a
cigar and says welcome to hell he stands
up and he looks at the window and it's
beautiful and sunny and he's like this
is hell and he goes oh they're lying
about what this is all about i'm here to
help you and they didn't like what i was
doing and making everybody a good time
free of worship and all that stuff he's
like wow really then he shows him around
all of his old friends are there people
he admires and looks up to her there and
they're like hey man good to see you and
he goes to a party and they're eating
all this good food and he's like this is
incredible and they were like yeah you
can't believe everything you hear of
course they're gonna try and tell you
what's bad here but we're trying to do
right by people we just don't agree with
what they want and then he was like wow
and then he sees all his friends and he
says goodbye to him and then all of a
sudden you know it's getting late he
goes back to his suite and lays down
goes goes to sleep and then wakes up
right before the pearly gates again and
then he was like that was incredible and
saint peter says well then which do you
choose because i want to go to hell and
then he goes okay snaps his fingers and
then all of a sudden he's in pitch
darkness he hears screaming and and
suffering and fire and then he looks
over and he's like
what's happening and then a large
grizzled nasty looking figure in the
same suit walks up and he says it's me
the devil and he goes but what happened
to the greenery the luxury and he goes
that was campaign season
good job
that's how it goes right it's very good
it's true all right gerald armstrong
says tim when are you getting kyle on
he's doing the rounds with crowder blaze
etc you know uh first of all like i
think crowder's the same thing like
immediately after the trial we were like
we're not gonna try and like reach out
and be like we have to have kyle right
now you know what i'm interested in is
actually i'd rather wait a little bit
um i know he was on you know with um
with elijah and sydney and they
said a lot of things and he was on with
crowder and he was on with tucker i'm
i'm not interested in trying to just try
and book someone because they just had
this big breaking news story i'd like to
book kyle maybe in like three months
when he's been watching the news this
story is a little bit behind him and
then here's opinions on where things
have gone and where things are i think
that would be more robust and also just
to be completely honest like trying to
compete for like one of the top
personalities of like right now is just
like
i just don't think you know i can do it
you know what i mean so he's
just a young kid which is why we like
and appreciate him and he did the right
thing in an incredibly difficult conver
uh this situation and saved his own life
so and then he survived the trial so
props to him but at the same time it's
like i would like for him to develop his
own views on everything hopefully become
like a strong advocate for 2a stuff and
everything but we'll see what he wants
to do i i think early yeah i think right
now it's like there's a lot of convert
questions to be had about what happened
and tucker carlson got that interview
broke that stuff down and that was good
yeah now i think i'd be interested to
wait as we get into midterm season and
then have him come on and you know flesh
out his thoughts and ideas on on other
subject areas otherwise it just kind of
feels like everyone's trying to get a
piece of the kyle rittenhouse story
right yeah so i went through this with
occupy wall street after i got a bunch
of attention and then every news outlet
was like interview the guy and i'm like
that's stupid i didn't do anything you
know what i mean like i get it you got
an interview i'm gonna go do my thing
that's how i feel when people call me on
my birthday call me the day before yeah
right don't don't call me randomly in
the year and say what's up how you been
you know what i mean yeah
but it's cool i'm glad i'm glad he's
going around talking to people i just
kind of feel like i don't really feel
like i can add anything by just inviting
him yeah you know but it would be cool
in a few months talk about midterm stuff
yeah absolutely
taka nokage says salvation is a gift
from god man cannot save himself through
good deeds god requires that we agree
with him that we are only capable of
wrongdoing belief that jesus died in
your place for your sins and that he is
resurrect and he res and that he
resurrected is what saves you
interesting so much hell has been
brought on earth
because of christianity and religion
like the the crusades maybe that was you
can't pin it on christianity the islam
and the people and it's probably more
about the people than the religion but
just to say like yeah i believe it now i
synchronize with god so i'm i'm good i
can do as much chaos and destruction as
i want i don't i don't vibe with that
the thing is that's not so this is
interesting you know reading john
mcquarter's book right he's very he's
obviously very hostile towards religion
it's very interesting and what struck me
as i was reading was like he kind of
believes religion to be like the spanish
inquisition or the crusades version of
religion which of course was terrible
right and i hope i hope no one disputes
this right but that's not the entirety
of christianity or or frankly you know
any one of these faiths that that you
know people seek redemption through or
enlightenment through it's just you know
it's it's also it's i suppose the human
reality of these religions right that
where things can go when things go
really bad i think a better way to look
at religion and people look at the
catholic church and they're like holy
cow this is full of terrible things that
happen and you cannot contest that that
is true but it might be wiser to look at
that and say something along the lines
of wow people are really screwed up and
they'll use any kind of cover to get
what they want whether it's politics or
argumentation or religion they do um and
the basic ten one of the basic tenets of
christianity is that people are
incredibly deeply flawed and thereby
need some form of salvation in the in
the form of jesus obviously so i don't
know maybe we're kind of looking at it
backward looking at the bad things
that's done maybe it's our
misunderstanding of human nature
we've got some super chats that i think
are in polish oh boy i can't read it
i'd love to can you read that i can't
wait for where where where uh
can we make it bigger
um i can you want me to walk up there
let me see if i can just do this
is that going to work
i think it's working
oh wait wait
i see something about okay
would mean like you know kind of like
take care of yourselves
we've had people post polish stuff
before but i can't read it so it looks
like i don't know what you're saying
it's nice seeing you try though
that's funny i keep i keep like oh i
don't know keep going tim yeah but i
read it with english phonetics so it's
just way off um the funny thing is when
i was in ukraine
there was a bunch of cyrillic
and uh we were walking into this areas
with my friend and there was a sign a
big banner and i was like so what does
that say and she was like it's english
and i was like
that's not english and she goes yes it
is it's just the cyrillic alphabet and i
was like really and she's like yeah it's
written in english and then when she
explained to me the sounds of the
cyrillic letters i was like wow it said
like international business festival or
something and it was literally
english crazy weird stuff backwards r
yeah circle with line in it that's not
right damn right
what's up says tim you should watch how
woke the game awards are they're pushing
propaganda normalizing things and making
gaming culture woke trash you should
focus on this more millions of
uninitiated watch it um we have pop
culture crisis for that reason to talk
about video games and not to be super
overt on politics just to be like why
can't i play video game you know what i
mean but i will say something
i just watched the order on netflix
they cancelled it
which is a bummer wasn't the best show
in the world
but
the villain in the second season
is literally a communist and i'm not
saying figuratively i mean quite
literally they go to this guy's house
and they find stalin books and like
marks
and his idea is like the show is about a
secret society with magic and they're
like they control it and his idea is
that everyone should be allowed to do
magic
this other woman who works with them
believes that there is a magic
incantation which can free magic users
of sacrifice meaning everyone will have
free magic and just be able to make
whatever they want happen whenever they
want and the woman who leads the group
the order says if it were possible don't
you think people would have done it by
now people have tried but a world of
free things just doesn't matter either
you pay now or you pay later and i was
like they're not talking about magic
they're talking about you know like
capitalism and yeah
the woman was overtly a communist though
they called her she calls her groups
or group praxis i thought it was funny
and i tweeted it and and then the
leftists were like but i don't want
politics in my my tv shows and i was
like yeah i i totally get that that's
why i think it's funny because now you
guys are are you know angry because
they're making fun of communists like
yeah i'd rather just watch a show where
a werewolf fights a vampire or something
i guess i don't know
but i thought it was good they canceled
it anyway
all right let's see where we are at
we've got a bunch of super chats here
um let's see people are talking about
steroids and sperm counts
all right mark ass says normally i don't
like some of ian's questions but today's
super a super is for ian finally making
sense for your information if you like
romance of the three kingdoms check out
the warring states in japan 1550. yeah
is that like odoo nobunaga and tokugawa
shogunate rise to power i think that
happened during the warring states
period i saw this really really great
documentary about you know the the late
1800s in japan it was called the last
samurai oh yeah i think um tom cruise
is a good movie but i'm kidding
i still like the movie no actually great
great film
i actually did watch a really great
documentary where it showed like the
warring factions the clans in japan yeah
and that was like bloody that was crazy
the sengoku period said gokuji die
that's what it's
as i heard you were having colin moria
moriarty at no taxation on is this
happening in january because of
everything going on
uh we didn't announce that though do we
we did not announce that that's kind of
interesting i wonder if he mentioned it
um we are gonna have him on uh sometime
in the first quarter according to him so
we'll make it happen yeah no worries
yeah we were um because we moved
everything around with the austin trip
had to reschedule seriously jk says
props to ian for asking a great question
and making a solid and cogent point it's
always refreshing and partially
redeeming for himself to see that go in
see you tomorrow this second super chat
that said but i don't know what they're
talking about
he's already forgotten what the heck
says tim search braves extension store
for return youtube dislike enjoy
i don't care about seeing the dislike
button
um because i already know
removing the dislike button stops people
from when they see cnn from realizing
everybody hates them
that's why they do it and joe biden yeah
they put cnn on the front page and msnbc
and abc and they're always down voted
thumbs down to oblivion and lord fauci
as well and lord fauci but now they got
rid of it so you can't see it
so so crusty and pathetic mind you did
you guys see that um
rumble threatened a legal action against
odyssey yeah but i didn't get the whole
context i don't know what odyssey did so
odyssey tweeted that rumble was
misleading its investors and using bots
which that's a bold accusation to be
completely honest you better have proof
they're using bots but they used
analytics that showed that rumble's
average like watch time was a minute and
a half or something and odysseys was
seven minutes and a half seven minutes
or whatever
something like that and the bounce rate
was was like i don't know some stats
like that and the reason to say people
aren't real it doesn't add up that
people aren't really watching the videos
and they said it was bots
and you know they're lying to investors
to make money or whatever and then
rumble send them a letter saying that's
not true those are wrong stats you're
including embedded video players
outside of the rumble website
acting like it's the rumble website and
then they said sue me go ahead like i
dare you show the world who you really
are and i'm just kind of like
i don't i don't know why odyssey tweeted
that
like that seems kind of weird like we've
complained about rumble but like only in
like a philosophical context of where we
think the future should go and we've
still complimented the fact that there's
competition no no legal issues with
what's going on with rumbles yeah but
like to to look at a bunch of evidence
and then assume a conclusion is super
dangerous
especially to look at a bunch of
evidence and assuming and assume a
conclusion like say
here's the evidence
this is no no they can't claim that
there are botnets because
to have no evidence and assert a truth
well to have statistics have some
evidence of bots and claim a truth it
would be like
looking at a blue flower and then
claiming it rained yesterday you're like
well i mean there's a flower and
sometimes it rains but doesn't prove
anything just because rumble's stats
were low and whatever metric they use
doesn't prove bots are being used at all
so to look at stats and say ah bots
you're like that's not evidence of bots
it's evidence of people not watching for
a long time right yeah to use that
evidence of
incongruences in the world why are they
fighting in the first place i mean what
like what's what's the the it feels like
there's like a kind of wide open space
here you know at the well moment i i
have concerns about
a big a company like rumble rallying
everybody on their platform and then
going public and making tons of money
and and i feel that there's a risk of
exploitation that ultimately results in
more censorship because it's hyper
because now it's it's public and anyone
can buy in and of course public
investors would revolt and make demands
and then you lose control even if you
have controlling shares
but uh at the same time i'm like well
any competition is better than nothing i
just think it's good that they did what
they did fine we need to make our own
thing
i i wouldn't accuse them of doing
anything like illicit it's super
important that people don't pass on
rumble right now i've seen people in
comments are like yeah down with rum f
rumble like no man come on right now
yeah rumble
why would you do that i mean you know
it's pretty clear there are some you
know very very questionable actors out
there and i you might want to look at
those
first right
it's tough man
like when i complain about rumble it's
basically because i fear that what
they're doing is not the direction
towards solving the problem of
censorship but at the same time it's
like a major net positive that rumble
locals and all this stuff is happening
because it competes with silicon valley
but it's big different to come out and
accuse them of malfeasance but how and
what is it with the censorship like how
does it not help going public opens them
up to these big institutional investors
so first of all um rumble
effectively sells merges with a company
run by an institutional investment firm
now you've got the institutional
interests they go public through the
spac then you know as ian pointed out
you get vanguard state street blackrock
they buy in then then as much as you
think having controlling shares means
they can't influence you is just not
true
when they control enough they can put
pressure on you in ways you can't
imagine yeah and then eventually they're
like
okay well actually it's it's like steve
bannon said he was like someone's going
to come to you and offer you 200 million
dollars you're saying this to me and
then they're going to say we're going to
give you 200 million dollars to expand
this and make a big show by our own
cable network
our only suggestion is you know maybe
get rid of luke he's a little too edgy
for us that's the game they play right
because like you know luke is is as
outspoken edgelord edgelord whatever
and so
i have the same view of what rumble is
doing they get this big money from an
institutional firm how long until they
say
look of course we don't want to
interfere you know i think it's great
that you're this neutral network that's
attracted so many people but
you know you've got this one guy who
uses the platform and he's putting us at
big risk look you don't got to ban
everybody and it's not it's not like
we're saying change the rules we're just
saying maybe you shouldn't allow this
one guy and then they'll be like well
you know they did give us 400 million
dollars so they start censoring people
working on is decentralized technology
so that you control it 100 so you can't
ban yourself unless you want to i guess
you just delete your server but then you
have control of everything so
but it's you know it is what it is
all right jacob jones says ian watch
real crusades history here on youtube to
get the full crusades context and that's
where you're
and that's where you're screwing up is
context and a pop culture understanding
of crusades history
interesting well thank you for the
real crusades
all right let's see daniel hansen says
you mentioned my mom sometimes when you
talk about the cafe owner who was
arrested across the minnesota border in
iowa in court this week and judge told
her she can't argue the
constitutionality of the executive
orders to jury this is tyranny wow man
we do yeah because
um i don't think she did anything wrong
by trying to survive in an economy where
executive decree violates the
constitution
and um you know what i can't give you
any legal advice but uh i would just
argue it
i'd quite literally bring it up and then
what's the judge gonna say
i'll hold you in contempt i'll be like
yo man you can either stick to the
constitution and allow me to explain the
constitution or you can say the jury
doesn't have the right to know the
constitution and you can lock me up for
however long you think you need to but
i'll keep saying it no matter how many
times you have a trial i will say the
american constitution
and then what i don't know lock me up
sure i guess
that's crazy man sorry to hear
all right let's see we got aaron kohler
says i am from waukesha this jesse
smallett type of mind crime has caused
us real physical harm
that's true man yeah
alex better says you can go to europe
unvaxed if you're a refugee hmm
uh quote unquote
indeed yep
flawedzilla says where'd you get your
beanies uh i think like active ride shop
or ccs skate shops skate beanies by the
way did you know we call those toques in
canada
beanie like how is that a beanie anyway
okay it looks like a bean i don't know
that's just a word for a hat
all right let's see we'll grab we'll
grab a we'll grab a couple more here
oh this one's i gotta read this one sep
septetrion tentrion says chip companies
selling air really grinds my gears
but you see what happens is they have
the bag the machine sprays all the chips
and it fills up to the top and then in
shipping it shakes and they all start
rustling down and compressing that's
just the way it works it's for cut
cushioning right no no no it's just that
when the chips are all laid on top of
each other there's a lot of
excess space when they seal it up and it
bounces around in shipping all of the
chips start compressing and sinking to
the bottom and especially when they
break yeah that's terrible yeah
all right
home b says here's ten dollars to
support the chickens go buy raspberries
they are delicious this year uh and the
chickens love it they love
eating the berries
we gotta get the chicken city camera set
up but ben was missing for a while but
we found him so we're all getting ready
yeah we put up the vlog
today because ben was missing but i
guess they they ended up figuring out
where he was gone for a few days and
people were freaking out there's like
missing person reports
pretty easily you know he texted back
like
yeah after four days people are like he
did vanish our
but he's all right so we're good we're
good we're good and now we'll get
chicken city set up so uh all right
everybody go to timcast.com
that website is where there will be a
all of the members only content and
segments there's a huge library of it
you can click it become a member help
support our work we're hiring more
journalists the more you guys just more
and more and more and we're building a
big facility we're getting a quote on a
new big corporate headquarters because
we're building our own building this is
crazy we're expanding like crazy and we
are going to hire a ton of people and
it's going to be nuts
and then maybe in 10 15 years i
shouldn't say maybe in 10 years we will
be a massive international news
organization and i will be like 80 years
old equivalent because i'll just be
worked in the bone too much but again
support our work at timcast.com smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel follow us at tim cass irl
basically everywhere you can follow me
personally at tim cast uh do you want to
shout anything out young
uh well
you know
epochtv.com check out the american
thought leaders programs uh you know
like i said we cover all sorts of a
range of uh you know interesting guests
and i think it's a bit like the deep
dive format that you mentioned that you
do in uh you know in the members only
only section
um and also you know i actually i have a
holocaust documentary that i produced
with my wife our father my father-in-law
is a holocaust survivor and he's just
this amazing man so we actually produce
something that's an optimistic holocaust
documentary it's called finding manny
finding manny.com you can check it out
there
um and actually it's still in the film
festival circuit so we'll be we'll be uh
putting up there where where it'll be
showing next and uh you know twitter of
course at yanya kellik
j-a-n-j-e-k-i-e-l-e-k
yep well my family also had to deal with
uh pretty much the same thing but jan it
was zaya bistia to have you on
that's a great word that's so great i
haven't heard that in a while
oh man that's just
freaking a you know something
it's one of my favorite terms but as you
can see i have my own matrix t-shirt on
today and i actually did a video on the
fourth movie that's coming out soon on
luke uncensored.com that was very
interesting i think you guys would like
it a lot and i have my own youtube
channel it's we are change so i hope to
see some of you guys there and uh thanks
for having me i love that shirt luke the
great resist that's a good shirt yeah
they will own nobody and they will be
unhappy
uh hey thanks for coming everyone i'm
ian crossland check me out ian
crossland.net and get in touch with my
socials contact me through there and i
will see you all later
thank you guys all for tuning in as we
talk with yon and enjoy the company of
our polish gentleman you guys may follow
me on twitter at sourpatchlits
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see all of you at timcast.com for the
member segment again thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you